AHHHHH!
Sorry everybody!
Sorry I forgot to let by the time!
The time fucking messed me up!
Oh my god!
Oh my gosh, sorry everybody!
I had to do some work stuff and I looked at the clock and I was like, Oh my god it's 5!
I was like, I don't have anything set up!
I'm so stressed out and I'm busy and I was like, Okay, I can get this done and then I was like, I'm like looking at time like, Oh fuck wait!
It's streaming time!
Did I finish the work?
The thing is, I'm never done with work.
I'm always working.
No but today is like, particularly...
Stressful because like, I might have... I received some concepts for my new...
For my new skin suit and I was like working on like trying to figure out if like, if it looks okay.
Like I was editing it and stuff.
So I was like editing my new skin suit and I was like with my tailor.
With my skin suit tailor.
And...
And I was like editing it and editing it and I was like, will this look good?
I was so stressed out.
I was so stressed out because I was like, oh my god I hope the dragoons will like this.
And I was like, what if they don't like it?
What if my fucking taste sucks?
What if I'm fucking terrible at like, what makes a good skin suit?
I'm like, aww.
And I was like stressing it out and I was sending it to somebody.
I was like, which one do you like?
The original skin suit design or like...
Or like what I did?
And then they said the original.
I was like, what's the point?
And then I had like a mini breakdown.
And I was like, what's the point?
I wasted so many hours editing this and trying to figure out what I want.
And then people still like the original more.
What's the point?
And I was like having a mini breakdown.
And then I was like, what if I just have bad taste?
And I was like, oh my god.
I just fucking be a tomato.
I don't care.
I was so stressed out.
Because I was like, this skin suit is forever.
I can't just take off the skin suit.
But I'm like, oh my god.
This is technically gonna be like my new main look forever.
What if I hate it?
What if I hate it but everybody else loves it?
What if everybody else hates what I think looks cool?
What if I'm like, this looks so cool.
And everybody else will be like, this sucks.
I'm like, no!
So like...
So that's why I've been like going through the past two...
Okay, the past like...
Two weeks.
This is what I've been going through.
But like the past two hours was me like...
Like fucking freaking out and trying to figure out like what looks good.
And I'm like...
I was like, this has to look good.
This has to look like me.
My personality.
Everything I like.
And like it still has to be unique but not too complicated.
Because I don't like...
I don't like it when it's too cluttered or too much.
It has to be like easy to cosplay but not too easy to cosplay.
It has to look good on merch.
It has to tell a story.
And I'm like, I hate this.
I hate...
I hate trying to fucking figure this out.
I was just like...
No!
That's repulsive.
Think about it.
It's been a mess.
Like you bring a good look at me.
It just has to be recognizable.
Like a very unique polk star.
I know for sure it's going to be a mess.
It's been a mess.
It has to be recognizable with a unique silhouette.
But also not too unique.
Because you don't want it to be too messy and too cluttered.
But also you want it to look nice.
You want it to just look nice and be like that's a nice, recognizable design.
I'm like, I hate this.
And I'm like editing it and stuff.
I was like, okay, this is like so many ideas I have to make it look better and to make it look better.
And so like, maybe this will make it better as a skin suit and everything.
And then I sent it to a friend and I was like, what do you think?
Which one?
One or two?
One being the original, two being my edit.
And they're like, one.
I'm like, what's the point?
I spent an hour and a half editing this.
What's the point?
I'm like, if you want to see it, you can.
If you think like that, then what if the dragoons don't like it either?
And so that's what... So yeah, I had a mini breakdown.
I had a mini breakdown and I spent like the last 15 minutes getting myself together.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
It's your skin suit.
You should focus on making it comfortable for you.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
But what about the branding?
But what about the branding and needs to have good branding.
So it's so painful.
I wish I can just like hire somebody to do this.
But then like...
Oh my god, it's so painful.
But like, technically I did, but it's just like...
I did so much work, so much.
I woke up stressed.
And then, not gonna lie, streaming has actually been my only place to escape.
Like, that's why I love streaming so much.
I stream so I can escape off stream life, which is behind the scenes stuff.
I stream so I don't have to worry about... I like escape my behind the scenes work and how much work it is and everything.
And I get to spend it with you guys too.
You guys... you guys evalute my stress for me.
That's why I stream.
Every time I get to stream, I'm like, oh my god, thank god.
I get to escape from work.
I get to escape from actual work.
It's my escapism.
Alright, anyway, today...
Sorry, I had to go through that little...
Little rant today.
Um...
Little rant today because holy fuck it.
I've been like really stressed out since waking up.
Um...
Richie, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
The brand is Doki Bird.
There's no question about that.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Anyway, everybody.
We are playing HOT.
Hello, Cure!
Yeah!
I don't know if this game has a full screen because like...
When I opened it up...
Um...
Like...
Uh...
When I opened it up, it gave me this.
It's like not full screen.
And I was like, whoa!
It's so tiny!
Oh, it does?
Okay, because I was wondering if we were...
We should...
We should watch this intro.
Ba-ba-ba-na-na-ba.
Ba-dum-ba-dum-ba-dum-ba.
I love...
The artwork is so pretty in this game.
Ba-dum-ba-dum-ba-dum-ba.
I know like the music and I actually...
Uh...
The...
Okay, let's see.
Graphic settings.
There we go.
Oh, there we go.
Nice.
Can I...
Oh, there we go.
Full screen.
Yay!
We get full screen!
I don't know if the volume is okay.
Let me turn it down a little.
Maybe?
I don't know, guys.
I hope the volume is okay, chat.
Uh...
But yeah, I'm super excited to finally play Holog here.
It's been a game that I've been wanting to play for a very, very long time.
I heard it's like...
Really addicting.
And...
The biggest crime is that this game is free.
Like...
This game...
I know like...
Because this is like Passion Project.
So I know like why it's free.
And it's actually crazy that this game is free.
Because I was reading the reviews and...
And like a lot of people are like, oh, I don't really know much about Hololive.
But like this is an actually really fun game.
Like I don't know like the...
The...
I don't know like the story behind this.
Or I don't know like how to...
Like I don't know the lore behind this.
But it's a really fun...
It's a really fun game.
And the fact that the creator wouldn't even...
Was like refused to like accept donations or anything or be paid for this is actually...
Um...
Like insane.
Because like bro, you deserve money for making this game.
Like holy shit.
I'm getting rid of screen shake.
Because I've always hated screen shake.
But yeah, how's the volume chat?
I'm worried it might be too loud.
My sound guy has been like...
Some stuff has came out for my sound guy.
So like I will have to rely on you guys to help me with the volume control.
A bit loud?
Okay, let me turn it down a little bit then.
Let's see.
I'll turn it down a little bit.
No, I'm thinking of the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, wait, sound guy's here!
Okay, let's see.
Turning it down.
Sound guy!
I hope everything's okay with you!
But yay!
Sound guy's here!
Okay, let me see.
Turn it down the music a little bit more.
Okay, let's see.
Where is the music?
I love my favorite time.
My...
Oh wait.
I love...
My favorite time is sound control.
Uh...
Yippee!
Sound guy!
Alright, turn down the music a little bit.
Um...
But yeah, but I understand though, because like, what I really admire is the whole...
They set...
Hololive set up this whole like, holo indie thing, which is providing like funding and support to indie developers, which is really admirable.
But I know like the creator of Holocure is not in there because they wanted to like still keep up this passion project and stuff.
So, which is understandable because the thing about passion projects is that you have the control of your vision and everything.
So, like, you know, like corporate, like, you know, you don't have to answer to something higher up to you regarding changes or things or like you want to edit some things to fit more of what the people in the higher ups would want for it.
So it's understandable why this kept was free and also not part of the holo indie, the holo indie project because it is a passion project.
Like what he wants to do is reflecting on what the fans want and what he, his vision is.
So that's like really understandable and it's like really honorable thing to do.
And, and yeah, you don't have to listen to like what, like, you know, not just like Matt what management wants, but also like other people, other people that are funding the company and stuff like that.
So it actually is like, cause like, you know, what if like they want to remove something or if they want to add something that might not be from the vision of the original creator.
So that's why it's understandable why this is still a passion project.
And the fact that they're doing all of this due to their passion for this company and the passion for like, uh, the individuals who are a part of like hololive, like the talents and everything.
It is very, um, you know, like the passion of the fans, um, is very admirable and everything.
But yes, I've always wanted to play this game.
Everybody makes it look so fun.
I like watched a couple of streams of people playing this and it's very similar to a, uh, vampire survivors, which is why I was really interested in this because I've seen people play vampire survivors when they were, and then I've only played vampire survivors once among us edition.
So that's why I wanted to play this for a while now.
And, um, it seems like an incredibly addicting game.
Um, and the fact that it still gets updates too.
All right.
What's meta?
I just love you guys are like, no, pick the character that you enjoy.
Click the talent that you enjoy the most.
No, as, as a gamer, it is called pick the character that's meta.
It's all about winning.
I need to know what is meta.
Right now out of the five.
Talents that are here.
Who has, who is the most meta to start out?
Uh, right now is Mori.
Okay.
Swings in half circle arc in the front.
Stage mode.
Okay.
Defeat the last boss to complete.
Well, obviously I haven't really unlocked anything yet.
Um, so I guess I'll do the stage mode.
I've okay.
It's like the beginning level of vampire survivors.
All right.
Go.
Okay.
W A C left click to toggle or right click to aim.
What left click to toggle.
Oh, what can I aim here?
What do I aim?
Where does the aim part come from?
I guess if I have like a special ability.
Question mark.
Use a controller.
No.
M I K forever.
All right.
Nice.
I want to be a controller for it.
Where, where.
You aim your attack, but I can just move around.
I just move around for that.
All right.
Give me that box.
Your main weapon can be adjusted.
Oh, okay.
But at the moment, I don't think I have anything.
All right.
15% chance to negate one hit.
Uh, uh, when defeating a target, you need to lock it.
You can strafe while attacking.
Right click aim.
You can strafe.
Holy shit.
This game is much more complicated than I thought.
What the fuck.
Okay.
Increase damage.
Oh my god.
I'm so confused.
Who would have thought this game was much more confusing, much more complicated than I expected.
Oh, my gosh.
I remember when I watched Morrie's debut, I like, I think I live tweeted it too.
I want to click on that.
I'm pretty...
I'm pretty sure I live tweeted Mori's debut and she...
Let's see... when like Myth first came out.
We maxed out the Scythe, right?
Who?
Okay guys.
I already took one damage because I was fucking around too much.
It's okay.
I have experience.
I played Among Us Vampire Survivors.
It's fine.
Apparently in the meta is to max out the Scythe.
We gotta kill the dead Beats first.
It's okay.
They enjoy it.
I mean they're technically dead already.
So is it really killing them?
Alright.
Max out the Scythe.
Oh, this is not good.
This is not good.
This is definitely not good.
Oh, okay.
That was just a bait.
It's just bait.
I mean...
Since they're dead already, it doesn't really matter.
If we kill them again.
Because technically they're dead.
So they just come back to life.
Do they have orbs here too?
Reduce the time between attacks.
Wait.
Four?
Yeah, we're saving them.
Oh, you're right.
We're saving them.
By killing them.
Exactly.
One or three.
All healing is doubled.
Four?
Okay.
Four.
It's okay.
I let my chat tell me what to do because I can't think for myself.
This is for your own good.
Do not worry!
Alright.
One.
We're gonna max it out still.
Holy shit.
I'm so fucking strong now.
I think it's like...
The fact that like all this... like all the iFans came together to make this.
Because it's a huge team too.
That made this game.
That was nothing.
I got scammed.
Like the art.
The music.
The gameplay being more...
There's like a home decorating thing!
There's fishing!
There's fucking fishing!
Wait.
Is it three?
Is this the max?
This is the max, right?
Oh my god.
That's a big guy!
That's a big shrimp.
Oh no no no no no no no no no no!
No!
Don't worry, thread the needle.
Okay, don't worry.
We can kill him.
Can't be that bad.
Is that the boss?
The mini boss where he gives you a chest?
I don't know what the hololive equivalent is.
Oh my god, he's so tanky.
He's so fucking tanky.
Alright, we maxed out the scythe.
For Callie, headphones are a good choice because she has a small dead spot in her scythe swing.
When you unlock specials, Callie can do big damage easily.
Thank you for the super chat, Richie.
Thank you, thank you.
One?
Increase attack by two.
Okay, one.
Alright.
I got this too.
Open.
Hollow's done.
What did I get?
What?
Oh, BL book.
Repels target with orbiting BL books.
What is...
Black licorice?
Wait, BL stands for black licorice, right?
Right, guys?
What else would it stand for?
Yowie?
That's a Y.
That's not yowie.
That starts with a Y.
One, two, three, or four.
Richie, thank you for the super... Oh, I already read that.
Brother, thank you for the one gifted chest.
Thank you, thank you.
Two?
When defeating a target, there is 30% chance...
to life steal 2 HP.
If taking a hit while HP is less than 15% chance.
Oh, God.
Okay, wait, wait, wait.
Just gotta get rid of these guys here.
Just keep going, right?
It's okay, I'm gaming.
Look at that.
I played Vampire Survivors.
It's okay.
I played...
I played Among Us Vampire Survivors.
I know what I'm doing.
It's pretty easy.
Alright, for each target defeated... I'm gaming.
I already know the strat.
Okay, turn down music one more notch.
Okay, sound guy wants me to turn down music one more.
All healing is double one.
For each target defeated, increase attack.
Okay, I'm gonna do attack.
We're gonna be like...
We're gonna be like a glass cannon.
I can't die if I kill everybody first.
What is this?
Okay.
Sound guy said the music is just a little bit too loud, so I turned it down a little bit.
But if it's now too quiet, let me know.
One or two.
Okay.
When do things get harder?
Oh, big taco!
Get over here.
Okay, I never told this to anyone.
But now...
I mean, I can post it now.
Tweet it out now.
But I actually have a...
Oh, wait.
In a minute?
Wait, guys.
No, that was a joke.
I don't want things to get a little bit...
Harder, guys.
I'm happy with the current difficulty.
I don't need things to be a little bit harder.
But I actually...
Okay, wait.
Let me grab one, two, three, four.
When do you feel like you're on target?
Scythe, swimming, or death?
Oh, this is new!
Death!
Alright, two?
Okay.
I actually own a...
A...
Oh my gosh, wait.
I can't think!
Okay, two again?
Alright, when defeating a target, two.
Okay, two.
Alright, now I get to open.
Alright.
Anyway!
There's so many things on the screen!
It's so hard to talk!
I actually own...
Okay, headphones.
Super headphones.
40% chance to...
Hit and heal 10...
Oh, it's a Supa!
Okay, I'll take it.
Super is good.
I might not play gacha, but I know Super is good.
But I own a little...
A little...
A little taco.
A little taco figure on my desk.
Thank you for the five gift this ship!
Thank you!
I can actually show it on Twitter.
I just recorded it.
Thank you!
Oh...
And she is even red!
Thanks for the two.
Okay, three?
Three?
Throw an axe at Spylus?
One?
Three?
Three.
Okay.
I'll do three.
Okay, that's fine.
That's fine.
Everything's fine.
It's fine!
They died so fast!
It's fine.
Oh, they missed!
Nerds.
I imagine missing.
Alright, increase size of axe by 20.
Gain 1% crit buff every second.
Add one additional book.
Multiply all damage dealt by 1, 2, 3, 2, 1...
One?
Okay.
It's axe time.
I hope the music isn't too quiet now and it's at a reasonable...
Wait, I watched Hollowfest!
Okay, give me a second.
Let me see.
Everyone's gone!
Every time...
Every time I wanted to talk, have a conversation, I was like, give me a sec, guys.
We need to think again.
We need to think, guys.
Give me a sec.
There's so many things happening!
I can't have a conversation!
Sorry, I just leveled up.
Oh yeah, I watched...
I watched Hollowfest.
It's actually like...
Oh my god, fuck!
Okay.
I know how much work wearing those like 3D shit is.
So like...
So the dancing and all that's the... I'm aware how much fucking work all of that is.
So it's always very impressive and like...
I very admire them for able to do all...
The fucking flip!
Holy fuck!
All the cartwheels and stuff.
Alright.
Oh my god.
It's always... It's super fucking impressive.
Cause I like... It is a lot.
Cause like not only that, you have to do like dance classes.
Like... There's like dance classes too.
To be able to dance like that.
And...
Like obviously the choreo depends on like...
What they want to do for choreo.
What the fuck?
Where... Where's my sight?
Where am I doing?
Deadpool, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Don't think.
Just jam.
Alright, which one?
3 increases attack size.
Thank you.
This is Chat Plays Holocure.
Welcome to Chat Plays Holocure.
I'm the bot here.
Controls for you.
Alright.
Here we go.
Oh hey!
There's a gator.
Ohhhhhhh!
Okay, there we go.
We're fine.
We thread the needle.
Okay, I got a little bit distracted there.
But we thread the needle.
I'm full HP!
This is so fucking easy!
That's right.
That's why I'm...
I put my name in a Doki FPS.
Catch me at the leaderboards.
Doki FPS.
Oh please!
Give me the box!
Let's see.
Reach target.
Why do I even need to read this?
I can just let you guys read this for me.
Those headphones are saving you.
No, I'm saving.
I'm saving the world.
Uh, 3, 2, 1.
Okay, targets will take 15%.
1 for each target.
I see more 3s.
Okay, I see more 3s.
Open!
Open time!
Let's see.
All healing is doubled.
I'll take it.
I don't need a thing.
Oh, I got leveled up again!
Uber sheep.
Increased movement speed.
1?
Increases attack size.
1, 2...
I like how someone was like, 1, 2, 3, 4.
Thank you.
Very helpful.
Okay, 3.
No!
No, no, no, no, no, no, no!
Oh, it's fine.
It's fine.
We're okay.
We just luckily got health by defeating people.
We're fine.
Everything's fine.
I need to like grab some more dolls.
Nope.
Get out.
Back out.
What's the lore anyway?
Why are the fans...
I didn't read the beginning.
Pick 5.
Back to thinking for the Akasupa.
Thank you.
Let's see.
1.
Increased damp.
5.
1.
2.
Okay, 1.
I see more 1s.
I know like we all saw the intro, but what is the lore?
I don't know.
It's like anまり mera.
It's like one of my favourite things I've seen.
Oh, cool, cool, cool.
Let's go ahead with the практиc.
1.
Coed?
Poorarya.
1.
It's not delusional.
Get it over here, bro.
1.
Get over here.
I'm not afraid of you.
Oh my god, he has a bat.
Why don't they just get a gun?
We need a fan mascot who just holds a gun.
But I think that might get you... might actually get like...
I don't think that's good for merch though.
Wait, they do get guns?
Wait a minute!
No!
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no!
Okay, we're fine.
We're fine.
We're... we're threatening Danita!
We're threatening Danita!
Wait, they do have guns?
Alright.
Let's see.
Everyone is meta.
Okay, welcome to America.
One or three?
I'm gonna...
Okay, one.
I see more ones.
Oh god.
Oh, I'm so fucked.
I am so fucked up.
That map fucked me up.
I looked away for one second.
Oh my god.
That... that area actually messed me up a lot.
Holy shit.
Okay, I'm back to full HP.
I'm back to full HP!
Agent, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
We must cure them from being delusionals with the good old bonk stick.
Alright.
Let's see.
Three?
Three.
Okay.
That's alright.
Nothing bad happened.
Jesus Christ, chicken.
It's okay.
I'm back to full HP.
It's like... Oh my god.
Why are the KFP so fucking weak?
Okay.
Where's the box?
Where did I miss the box?
One, two, one.
I'm sorry, KFP.
Sorry!
Sorry, I don't get it.
Okay, create the lore accuracy.
I'm just... I... look at... look at...
I'm just asking questions here.
I'm just... I'm just asking the questions of what I'm... what's going on on my screen.
They missed two?
Alright.
Oh, nurse is horn, psych-axe, workaholic.
That's me.
Uh...
She's asking dangerous questions.
Uh... four.
Okay.
Nice.
Oh my god, that's all of it?
I swear I had more.
I swear... I thought I had more arrows.
Or gain 15...
Peaky... Oh, uh...
Thank you for the 50 gifted chefs!
Thank you, thank you!
I really appreciate it.
Thank you so much!
Okay, see more twos.
Oh, and then we have more.
Oh my god, I'm looking up like crazy.
Am I doing well for my first run?
Or am I...
I can't tell!
I can't tell if I'm doing well for my first run or if it's just like that.
Uh... three or... uh... so far?
You're doing fine.
Decent?
Guys, come on!
Our first... you're right.
Our first run.
Uh...
Let's see... one...
Alright, nice.
Holy shit, my axe is huge now.
I mean, it's the first stage?
Yeah, but like... but like this is my first try.
Guys, as a...
Guys, as a streamer, I said that so you can give me an ego boost, you know?
Yes, guys, you know, whenever a streamer is like, Hey guys, am I doing well for my first try?
Your... your reply would be like, Oh my gosh, Doki, you're doing amazing!
You're... wait, what?
Wait, okay, I can dodge that.
It's like Touhou.
You'd be like, wow!
Doki, you're doing so good!
It's like you're... you're a fucking gamer!
You're supposed to be like boosting my ego here.
Can I kill this thing?
I can't tell!
I don't know if she...
Yeah, yeah, I can.
They have a... they have a shield.
That means I can kill this thing.
Okay, nice.
Easy.
Alright.
Open.
Uh...
Oh, hey, nice.
Nice.
More black licorice.
Uh...
It's a halfway boss.
We're halfway!
But we don't like to lie.
What do you mean?
Four.
Alright, more books.
More black licorice.
Man, I sure do love black licorice.
Because what else would BL stand for?
Uh...
Oh, we can max it out!
Okay, let's max this out.
Okay, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you!
Your micro could be better.
Callie is carrying you!
Look!
I'm just playing meta!
There is nothing wrong with playing meta!
Whoa, what's this?
What is this?
Combo?
Nah.
What does... what does this do?
Is this good?
Lab?
Oh my god, I can't believe it.
Black licorice.
What is it?
Black licorice?
Um...
That... I don't know if you guys know what that means.
But it's like when two black licorices love each other very much.
You try to eat two at the same time.
That's what it means, chat.
That's...
That's what it means.
Um...
Thank you, thank you for the magenta soup!
But thank you, thank you!
Don't know if you noticed, but items that have a star belong to that specific talent.
So you can grab them, upgrade them, while worrying about them taking up a weapon slot.
Oh!
That's really interesting.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you!
One.
Oh, so this doesn't take my weapon slot.
Because I'm Callie.
Alright.
Thank you guys.
Thank you for...
Oh my god, I'm...
I can just stand still.
I don't even know where my weapon is anymore.
I'm right here.
I can just stand still.
I can't wait.
You know, I can't wait for the real gameplay.
Fishing.
I...
I'm so excited.
I can't wait, chat.
The real gameplay.
Fishing!
I am the weapon.
The endless black licorice!
Oh my god, it's like I'm opening my own chocolate factory.
Uh...
Fishing is hard?
How?
It's fishing!
Is that...
It's like the best...
You can't make fishing difficult.
It's fishing!
Nightly milk.
Increase attack size and knockback effects of weapons by 20%.
Also increases pick up range by 50%.
Alright, we're halfway point.
10 more minutes of...
Ooh.
Okay.
Oh yeah.
Oh my god.
Hell yeah.
This is it.
I can't see anything.
I can't see the enemies.
I can't see anything at all.
Oh god.
Oh my god.
Okay.
I made it.
It's actually so difficult.
I...
Where am I?
Holy shit.
There's too many things swinging.
Reduce opacity.
Wait, I can do that?
Okay.
Reduce opacity.
Oh my...
Oh my god.
Thank god.
Thank you guys.
This is so much better.
I can actually see now.
There's so many questions.
Quality of life stuff.
That's really helpful.
Okay.
Threading the needle.
Whoa.
Alright.
Honestly, I'm surprised.
I'm surprised that I did as well as I thought I did.
Wait.
You can do that?
What a streamer.
Three.
Drop lava on the ground.
Okay.
Well.
That's good.
Oh.
Thank god.
We're doing it.
Oh.
There's a big clock!
Hello.
It's time to ... It's time to get you out.
Get out of here.
Can't.
There can only be one big clock.
Get out.
Down with the clock.
I'm always afraid of saying clock because I can slip up and say the other.
Haha.
The giant big clock.
Nice clock, bro.
Nice clock.
Okay.
What do we get?
Oh, a nurse's horn.
Level 2.
I guess we should take it.
Because we already have it.
What?
I'm just talking about clocks.
How is he going to tell the time?
The bigger the clock, the easier it is to tell the time.
That's really...
They don't call me the big Ben for nothing.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You missed my first super once you're back in the main menu, click the achievement section.
It'll tell you how to unlock weapons and items.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I don't need to have the game tell me.
I have chat to tell me and it's like instant.
Who needs...
Who needs to have the video game tell me what to do when we're doing chat plays holocure?
That's actually so nice that you can decrease the opacity of the attacks.
Because like... that was like one of my biggest gripes with... wait, can I do more?
Upgrade?
Oh, what do we upgrade?
Imagine reading.
Exactly.
We don't need to read.
Let's see.
The scythe?
Upgrade to scythe and... Oh I can upgrade!
Oh yeah, up scythe.
I'll do the...
Wait, spider?
Lava?
Well it's too late.
Wait, cast?
Okay, upgrade.
Yay!
I got an achievement!
Let's go!
Yay!
Oh my god, they have clothes now.
What are you doing?
Why do you have clothes?
Oh, it's because of the song!
I understand that reference.
Oh, it's over here.
Okay, nice we dodged it.
We'll give you clothes.
Okay, nice.
I was worried about having the tree block me.
Q?
Oh, is that my alt?
I don't need to use the Q.
It's like... Oh, wait.
I thought you were talking about the MV!
For some reason I thought you meant...
Because Overwatch Ultimate and Apex Ultimate is the Q button.
So I was like, I have an alt?
But you're talking about the music video Q.
Which makes a lot more sense now.
Sorry, I had gamer brain on.
I heard this game does have alt though.
So then I honestly thought you wanted me to press Q.
I know this has alt, so I honestly thought you were like...
Guys, alt, alt!
There's so many people!
You should alt.
Alt!
Increase area.
I do have an alt though.
I have to buy alt?
Oh my god.
Capitalism.
You can't even escape capitalism in VTubers.
You never escape capitalism.
Can't believe it.
Pay the Q.
Pay my imaginary currency because the creator won't accept anybody's money.
Alright.
I'll just kill these trans first before I go for the box.
Oh nice.
Okay, that's a little bit too many.
Fake capitalism!
That is worse than real capitalism.
Because it's a choice.
Oh my god.
I'm like, fucked.
There's a lot of dead meats and shrimps on me right now.
Uh...
Okay.
Nice.
We're fine.
Yay!
Woah!
Sorry, we're back to full HP.
We have to head downstairs though because...
I need to figure out a way to head downstairs because there's the other box over there that I kept.
I need to get the other box.
There it is.
Yeah, I was trying to get the other box.
Okay.
Increase damage.
Nice!
Alright.
Yeah, we got circled around!
Uh...
Max out her main weapon and get the trumpet sticker.
Thank me later for...
Alright.
Nice.
Oh hey!
This is saplings.
Wait, is that what they look like?
I thought they...
I thought they were just like seeds.
Hahaha!
Alright, and then there's the humans.
I think like...
When you become a VTuber, one of the hardest things...
Is to think of...
Oh no, please.
Please, I was trying to have a conversation!
Please!
Why every time?
Hahaha!
Why I have a conversation?
Okay.
Anyway.
Anyway, as I was saying...
I think one of the hardest things ever...
As a...
As a VTuber...
Is when you have to think of like...
Good fan names.
Hahaha!
And also like...
Fan designs too.
Like the...
To have like a mascot representing your fans.
That's like one of the most difficult things.
It's cause it's all about branding!
Hahaha!
It's all... I fucking hate branding!
Three.
Okay, increase damage.
I hate branding.
Cause it's like...
You wanna be like...
You wanna be like the next Hello Kitty.
Hahaha!
Oh god, where?
Where?
Oh god, okay.
Oh my god, there's way too many people!
Okay, here we go.
And there's like pillars too.
Please.
I'm trying to talk about...
Branding!
Please don't want it to be too complicated.
Cause you want the fan mascots...
To be easy to draw.
But you also want it to be cute.
But you don't want it to be too girly.
Because then...
Hahaha!
Cause you want the fan mascots...
To appeal for both...
For both boys and girls.
So it's like... Oh my god.
No!
Leave me alone!
Okay.
What did you...
You dropped three things.
Hahaha!
Alright.
Alright, what do we...
What do we do?
Three?
The lava?
Is it lava time?
It's lava time.
Oh, and it's free!
Oh god, please.
I have so many arrows.
Okay, here we go.
Please, let me have this!
Whatever this is!
Okay.
Cooking?
Alright, spider cooking.
Oh!
Alright, nice.
We're fine.
We're alive.
The best thing about...
Holocure is that like...
It'll always be update, right?
Right, Kay?
Hahaha!
This game will always be getting updates.
Right?
Right, Kay?
Hahaha!
Because...
Because there's always gonna be...
New members coming in.
So that means this game will always have...
Uh... will always have updates.
And I think that's really great.
Because... and the fact that it's free too.
Oh god.
Ohhhhh!
It's fine.
We're fine.
This game is getting a little bit harder now.
This game is...
No pressure or anything.
Of course.
No pressure.
Hahaha!
Alright.
Uh...
Which one?
3?
Increase the frequency?
Alright.
Wait, 1 minute left?
Wait, really?
No!
I should have run endless!
This actually is pretty addicting.
But I don't think I should do endless when I...
Um... don't even have a fucking ult yet.
Uh...
Let's see...
Sean, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Fun fact, back when this first launched, Kiara was pretty low tier.
Kiara then persuaded the dev and quickly updated her in a patch.
Now she's probably one of the easiest for beginners.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
That's interesting.
I mean, I guess because they're based off of like, you know, actual talents, they can just be like, why does my character suck?
And then...
And then get...
And then be like... get like patched to become the beefiest fucking character in the game.
Hahaha!
It's just that easy.
But then there's like the whole morality of that.
Hahaha!
Yeah, give me buff.
Make me the strongest character in the game.
Okay.
It's okay, we're fine.
Everything is fine.
I mean...
Hahaha!
If I have a character based off of me and I was an OP as fuck during launch, of course I'd...
I'd put peer pressure to do that too.
Do I just die?
I think I just die, right?
Oh no.
This is way too many people.
Oh, the arrow.
Fuck!
I forgot about the arrow!
Gamers don't look...
You have to tell me these things earlier!
Oh shit.
Oh, that's a...
Oh no, big o... No!
Big Omi, please!
Please!
Let me get the arrow!
Oh, okay, okay.
She has...
a cooldown.
Big Omi has a cooldown.
Big Omi.
Oh, she's dead.
I killed Big Omi.
Okay.
Nice.
I had small knockback.
Oh shit, wait, no I didn't...
No, I didn't kill her!
She fucking...
She's gonna pound me!
Okay.
What do I get?
Uh, a four.
Okay, guys, we gotta run.
We gotta run.
Big Omi's coming.
It's fine.
Just keep running.
Oh god, we'll go right...
Why did I go right?
We'll go down.
Okay, we just have to, like, make sure that our main attack is on her at all times, so we don't have to...
Oh god, I keep accidentally clicking it!
I'm just reflexively clicking my buttons when I don't need to.
It just locks the crosshair.
Wait, why the fuck would I need controller?
Mouse and keyboard is, like, doable.
Does controller actually make you a better player in this game?
I don't understand.
Where?
Oh, there's the arrow!
Wait, we have to kill Big Omi first.
Because she's closer.
And she has to be close to dying, right?
I'm following the arrow.
Guys, you have to yell at me if I don't follow the arrow.
Oh god, that was scary.
I thought I died.
I...
...
Let's see.
Three?
Two?
Okay, three.
Wait, she's the end boss?
Oh, okay.
Alright.
Before I kill her, I must loot.
Like a true gamer.
Oh, it's a gold anvil!
...
Okay.
Oh god.
Alright.
How do we do this?
What is the best combo?
I'm also sort of getting locked in right now.
...
Three?
And then...
...
Which one?
One plus two?
Wait, what?
Oh, one...
... One and two?
But I can only do one!
Oh, not three?
How do I cancel?
Oh, one and two.
There you go.
This?
Okay.
What does this make?
...
Unknown side effects if consumed.
What kind of unknown side effects?
Alright.
Now we're good.
We should be good now.
... We have like...
... We have no more arrows.
It's just big Ame.
... Yay!
... Let's see.
Electric heart.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you thank you.
KFP uses their own KFP as food.
Do you really think Yara would care about something like morels?
... Hey!
Oh shit!
I did it!
First try!
Yay!
I got so... I got like twen... fifth... like... not... okay.
I got like...
like ten achievements from that.
Alright, do I go back to the main menu?
Main menu and then... I heard you can gacha for other characters.
Now buy special.
Main menu, right?
Increase haste by 10%.
Shoot a powerful laser beam through the microphone.
Blacksmith gear, credit card, gorilla paw, hollow house.
Oh, I got more stages.
Oh my god, I unlocked everything.
Okay, shop.
Uh, upgrades.
How do I queue?
Special attack.
Oh, this is the... this is the alt, right?
Is this alt?
Alt.
Buy.
Is there anything else I should buy?
Uh...
Is there anything else?
Enchants.
Enchantments?
Here?
Alright.
And then... stamp... uh...
Stickers?
Which one's stickers?
Oh, is that stickers?
Drop by target, you can modify the main... okay.
Is there anything else I need?
Or is it gacha time?
Is it... a lot worth gains... uh...
Is it gacha time, or do you want me to unlock anything else?
Gacha?
Alright, what's armory?
Oh it's just the information.
Okay.
And then... this has the best character, right?
This is full meta, right?
Nexi, thank you for the 50 gifted chips.
Thank you, thank you!
Which is full meta.
It's all about the meta.
Okay.
Alright, we're gonna... Oh, debut.
Alright.
Okay.
Oh, hey!
Hey!
Alright, you're not meta.
I'm sorry.
No!
I need meta!
No, crony!
Why?!
Are you serious?!
I needed like...
one of these three!
And I get YouTube twice?!
Oh my god!
That's not fair!
I just wanted meta!
God, I'm so unlucky.
I can't believe it.
I just wanted meta.
I just wanted...
Metaaaa!
Alright.
Is...
Is Calliope still meta?
You know what?
Alright.
Ah, fuck it.
Let's go.
Alright, bae.
You...
You're gonna do meta.
We don't have meta, so...
Wait.
Recommended upgrades.
I don't need that.
I can do it.
Alright, bae.
You might not be meta.
But we don't need it.
We're gonna...
We don't need it.
We don't need it, bae!
You're not meta!
It's okay!
We're gonna be that...
We're gonna be that Overwatch one trick.
That tour-drawing one trick.
Oh.
I do need it?
No, we don't.
We don't need it.
Bae is a glass cannon?
Perfect!
I love glass cannon builds.
Okay.
Um...
Well, obviously, I have nothing else to upgrade.
Wait, bae is not his load tier?
Bae!
Tell the devs to buff you!
You have the power!
You have the power to tell the devs to give you a buff!
Okay.
Um...
Uh...
Fan, thank you for the magenta super!
Thank you, thank you!
Fun fact about the gacha.
You can do multiple pulls in one go.
Before you pull, there's an arrow indicating you can pull from 1 to 10.
Well, based on by a thousand holocoins.
Thank you, super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Alright.
It's fine.
I'm clearly very lucky, right?
It's not like...
This is it.
This is the day my luck turns around!
This will be the day!
Wait, what do you mean I just went for it?
I got...
No!
What do you mean?
I literally ran...
Oh my god!
What do you mean no?
I just looked at my chat!
I just activated hide mode?
Okay.
But...
Now my luck starts turning around.
Now!
This is it.
This is when my luck starts turning around, chat.
This is the moment!
It might not have been like...
It might not be like just now.
But this is the moment.
What the... I didn't read!
I didn't read the HALU!
What does HALU do?
I actually didn't read!
Oh, my god.
I read the chat.
Increase the regular VASPONs more.
Gain one for every four targets defeated since taking this...
WHAT?!
Increase regular VASPONs for...
No!
I'm not taking four!
I'm not taking...
Okay, now I read it.
I read it for real now.
Guys, it's okay.
This time I've read it, chat.
This time, we're not going to...
Alright, two.
I'll just hard upgrade the dice.
And because this is her...
Because this is her item.
Alright, it's fine.
We're fine.
I'm just going to go full on on the dice.
Nothing can go wrong with that, right?
Oh my god, please.
Oh god, okay.
It's fine.
I saved the burger up top.
It's okay.
Now I know to ignore every like, holo item for reals now.
Oh god.
It's fine.
He's not going to blow up.
Oh my god, this level.
This level.
Oh no.
No.
Babe, please.
Alright.
We go full in on the dice.
Oh no.
There must be another burger.
Where the fuck are the burgers?
Oh, there it is.
I knew I saved the burger.
Okay.
Nice.
Alright, we're good now.
Oh, gotcha.
Is that gotcha?
What is this?
Size to increase?
Yeah.
Yeah?
Apply this stamp to the weapon?
Apply it.
Oh, okay.
Nice.
Finish.
Alright.
There you go.
Do I have alt now?
Oh, I do!
Okay.
We're not going to use alt yet.
We have to like, wait.
We have to be patient, guys.
We need to find another burger.
It's okay.
We gotta wait.
We can wait.
We have to find another burger.
Okay, we're slowly...
We're slowly...
We're slowly turning back okay.
What is it?
Two?
Okay.
Two.
Use it and go le- Okay.
One.
Increase critical- Oh!
Critical hit chance is always good.
Wait, is this a boss?
What do I do?
Oh shit!
Oh, that's what I do!
We're not doing four.
Okay.
You can't trick me this time.
You can not.
You can not trick me this time.
I see ones, okay.
Oh, I got THREE!
I'll take all of that.
Throw an axe?
Fine.
Might as well.
Just take everything.
I'm fine with that.
Alright.
What do you want?
Uhhh...
Oh baby, a triple!
V for XP?
One?
No!
I almost...
Sorry, I almost... I actually almost clicked one.
I'm not clicking one.
That was close.
You guys almost got me there.
Oh my god, is that chicken?
Oh thank god.
Is this one hit if the player does not get attacked by target?
The target may become frozen.
I might as well.
Fuck it.
Just put everything.
Oh, I am not doing okay right now.
Bae... Bae why?
Oh god.
It's okay.
Do you have a head left?
It's like the li- I just realized it's like the library level.
I need more burgers.
I really need more burgers.
Okay.
Fine.
We can't go through this?
No.
Oh no.
Oh, that's not even a burger!
Okay.
Please.
Oh please have mercy.
What is the- is he spawning more?
Oh no please!
Okay.
We're going to go left.
No!
Bae please!
Oh okay.
We killed him.
Rest in peace all alive.
Burgers!
Oh god.
Where is my ult?
Okay...
Uh...
So...
I can't!
There's so many things in front of me!
I'm literally on life support right now.
I am on life support.
Here.
I have like nothing.
Oh god.
I live on.
I live on for just a little bit.
Oh my god!
I live on for like one second.
Please.
Holy shit, I was so close.
I'm heading to the arrow.
I'm getting there as fast as I can.
Oh, nice.
Fuck it, I might as well.
There's nothing more for me.
No!
Be defeated while using Halu.
I went to Halu.
Alright, shop.
It's gacha time.
I can do one gacha.
This is it.
This is where my life turns around.
Okay.
Alright.
Alright, this is it.
Do I have to upgrade anything or are we good?
Sana is good.
Wait, is she actually good?
Is she actually?
Is she meta?
Try to get Iris first for money meta to get to true meta later.
Customer, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Okay.
Alright.
I believe in you.
This is it.
I believe in you, Sana.
Okay, we need to have the...
Alright.
How is her attack?
Okay, it's like a circle.
Alright, I need more people to be around me.
I need more fans.
Alright, fans.
Get over here.
It's okay.
I can't believe it.
I can't believe you guys took advantage of me not reading.
That's so fucked up.
LOL
Sweet, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I overslept, but I'm here.
Hello, Doug.
Nice to see you.
I'm glad you were able to make it.
One.
Alright.
Nice.
We're just gonna stay here because this is like baby mode for now.
Guys, it's not because...
Callie was my crutch.
It's not because Callie was my crutch.
I am a gamer.
Okay?
Okay, it's just because I accidentally took Hanlu.
Or Halu.
Or...
It's because...
If I didn't take Halu...
If I didn't take Halu, we could have made it.
We could have made it with Bae.
I can... I can fucking beat any stage with any character.
It's not because...
Callie was a crutch.
It was because I just chose the wrong item.
My back seaters fucked me over.
Let's see...
One?
One or two?
Stop the cat.
I don't know what you're talking about.
I don't know what you're talking about, guys.
It's only because I got fucked over by Halu.
That was it.
It's only because of that.
All right, here.
Who would have thought you needed to read in this game?
I can't believe it.
Foiled by my lack of reading.
All right, here.
All right, what else, guys?
Skill issue...
No!
If it was a skill issue, there would be a journalist mode.
But there isn't.
Hmm?
There should be a journalist mode.
A journal...
Oh, wait, what's that?
What the fuck was that?
Wait.
Oh no.
I wonder what would Journalist Mode be?
Oh god.
Please.
Please be a burger.
Please, I need a burger.
Oh my god, what was that?
Wait, what is my ult?
Is my ult just big?
Just stand still.
Alright.
Is big.
Okay.
I'm just big.
Do I damage them?
By being big?
Oh, I do.
Oh, and I get to absorb!
Reduce the time.
Every 15 seconds, gain a 15 sec... 15 sec...
Okay, now every time you guys tell me to get something, I'm gonna read it.
Reduce the time.
Okay, that's her attack song.
Okay, now I'm gonna reduce... Is that like the... Is that the absorb?
Like the...
How is it called?
That like basically... Magnet, right?
That's the magnet, right?
The thing that glows?
I have trust issues now.
Oh god.
Oh my god.
This level is so difficult.
No!
When they said recommended, it was actually recommended!
I can't believe it!
The recommended upgrades was actually for real recommended!
Who would've thought?
That's crazy!
Who would've thought that shit was actually recommended for me?
Not me!
Oh god, I'm so fucked up right now.
Oh no.
Oh no!
This level is so difficult!
Leave me alone!
Oh no.
Oh no, this is really bad.
This is... This is so bad!
There's a maze!
Goodbye, son.
Oh, I'm sorry.
I'm sorry, son.
But I can gotcha.
This is it.
Meta.
Got!
This is not a crutch.
This is not a crutch, guys.
This is not...
It's not a crutch.
I swear.
I swear, chat.
I was just...
It's not a crutch!
It's just as intended!
For this, you need these upgrades.
I'm gonna ignore that because I can't read!
Look, I'm gonna show you!
We don't need those upgrades when I show you with Mori!
No!
We're gonna be so fine!
I'm gonna show you.
I'm gonna prove you all wrong.
It's because I haven't mastered Bay and Sana yet.
I just haven't mastered them.
But you'll see.
You'll see.
When I... When I beat this level on Callie.
Not because she is my crutch.
But because I'm that skillful at video games.
Okay.
Steven, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you!
Oh god.
Okay, don't worry.
We're fine.
Oh, more upgrades.
Nice.
Okay.
It's fine.
We're fine.
We're okay.
Good luck on the halfway, boss.
I don't need luck!
I was...
Oh!
Okay, it's fine.
It's fine.
Alright.
We don't need luck.
We're just that good.
Okay.
We just got...
It's literally the only thing that I haven't upgraded.
Don't worry.
I got a burger.
I ain't afraid.
Look at that.
See?
Look at all this money too.
Look at all this money that I got.
Look at that.
Alright.
Now I don't know what to do.
There's no scythe.
I don't know.
Now that there's no scythe, I don't know what to do anymore.
Pour?
Okay.
Nice.
This black licorice tab.
Okay.
We can...
We'll be fine.
Nice.
We KO'd him.
See?
Nothing to worry about.
Freaking easiest game of my life on worry.
No!
Not the burger!
My waste of a burger!
I'm not afraid.
What do we do?
What do we do, guys?
I have an ult!
I have an ult too!
Yeah, okay.
We're gonna use that for emergencies.
Two.
Alright.
Nice.
Alright, let's just grab all of this real fast and then grab this box too.
Grab the extra.
No!
It's for ult!
I already have ult!
Guys.
We're gaming.
We can do this.
I believe.
Nice.
Holy shit.
Okay.
This is... We don't need ult.
We don't need ult, chat.
We can live past this.
I guess we do the cooking?
What else do we need?
Customer, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Can't believe Calli's back problems.
Thanks for carrying.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
It is a group effort!
What do you mean?
If I... Okay.
If I die in this game...
It's your fault.
That means you're not very good backseaters.
Two... Three or four.
Three or four.
Or one.
One?
Okay.
I had to double check that I read that right.
I was like, wait a minute.
Is this what I think it is?
Like...
I was like, are you fucking kidding me?
Are you fucking kidding me?
Are you act... Like...
The one thing I got from the boss is the thing I don't...
I can't fucking pick up?
Oh, wait.
Isn't Norshorn really good?
Coward.
Think of the...
I am thinking of the coins.
On the level...
On the level where...
Oh, God.
Okay.
There's nothing there.
On the level where, like, I'm...
I'm...
I'm not ready for...
Wait, what do I... What does that do?
Wait, what does my ult do?
I couldn't tell.
What did my ult do?
Oh!
Wait, what did it do?
A crit buff?
Oh!
Alright, what did we upgrade?
I wasted ult?
I didn't know what my ult does!
My backseaters didn't tell me in time!
Two?
Two.
Okay.
Alright.
Oh, my God.
It does.
Okay.
We needed this.
We need more HP anyway.
We were, like, lacking in the...
Oh!
Oh, if only I was faster!
Why?
Why am I not faster?
Oh, no.
I'm gonna get lifesteal.
I really need the lifesteal.
Okay.
It's fine.
We don't need to be fast.
We don't need to be fast!
It's fine.
We just need to find a burger!
It's fine!
I'm stuck here.
Oh, I'm not stuck here.
I am not stuck.
It's fine.
We'll see if we're full HP now.
We're full HP.
Oh, no.
This is the boss.
The mini boss.
It's okay.
Alright.
What did we get?
Level 2 or level...
Look!
I saw somebody that said I was never gonna live past 4 minutes.
Pay the fuck up!
It's 4 minutes and 5 seconds.
It's...
There it is.
Pay the fuck up!
I did it!
I lasted 5 seconds longer!
I fucking did it.
This is an accomplishment.
Look, I didn't say which talents that I was gonna get this.
Okay, let's see.
I feel like I need more lifesteal.
Just because how fucked up I am right now.
Oh, God.
Please.
I need to grab more upgrades, but it's so hard.
Everybody is there.
Oh, my God.
Oh!
Okay, we're fine.
We're fine.
No, no, no.
We don't need all.
We're not wasting it!
Alright, what's this?
Energy drink.
Increase haste by 10%.
But reduces max HP by... no.
Why are they all so bad?
I'm not taking it.
What do you mean?
It says max HP by... by...
20%!
Take it?
Is it actually good?
I swear to God.
If you guys fuck me over...
Take it for...
Okay, take it.
Which one?
One?
Three?
Four?
Really?
It is...
Don't get hit.
I swear to God.
I swear.
I... I...
Oh, my God.
I'm so fast.
You're right.
I always knew you guys were right.
I always knew you guys wouldn't fuck me over.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
Okay, where is my...
Okay, we can... we can kill...
We can kill them.
So we can find... It's gonna be fine.
He's gold.
Get over here.
Get the fuck over here.
Get him over here.
Get over here!
He's golden!
That does you... That...
That means... Oh, God.
I think I had a heart attack.
That means you know he's good.
I was like... I think I had a stroke there.
Alright.
Nice.
We get money.
I have no idea if I picked the right one.
Oh, God.
Okay.
It's fine.
We're fine here.
See?
I told you guys.
I told you guys I could... This is the longest I survived.
He got... Wait, he got away?
I thought I killed him!
Rest in peace.
Alright.
Wait, one?
Okay.
How was I supposed to know?
He just disappeared as if he's dead.
Alright.
Which one, chat?
Here, thank you in the super chat.
Thank you.
Lose run.
Immediately spend run.
Loss winning on gacha.
Lose gacha.
Copium.
Thank you in the super chat.
Thank you.
Alright.
Nice.
And then...
Do we max out on a book?
Or do we get... Do we get the sunglasses?
Three?
Three.
Okay.
Yeah, there has to be a lot because I dropped a lot.
Okay, I guess we can... We can gain one more.
We can max out on that.
Nice.
We're doing great.
I believe in us.
I believe in our teamwork.
Chat.
Why are they so tanky?
Oh, they have shields!
Can I kill these?
Oh, no.
They just... It's just timed.
Oh, there's big boy.
Big boy is here.
I think this is the best mascot design I've ever seen.
This has to be...
Oh, fuck!
Oh, it's okay.
It's okay.
We're fine.
Oh, we are so healthy.
We are so healthy.
Dodge.
Alright, nice.
No, we don't need all... Okay.
I'm a coward.
It's fine.
Alright.
He's almost dead.
He has to be close to die, right?
He has to be close to die.
Nice.
I swear, if it's another Halu, I swear to fucking god.
It's three!
Okay, we gotta take the book.
And the cooking.
Do we take the fan beam?
Or is it useless?
Is that useless?
Or do we take...
Or take it?
Take all?
Alright.
I got the one person that was like, no.
Okay.
Alright, which one?
Chat.
Which one do we need to get?
Two?
Okay, two.
Nice.
Oh god, that's a lot of bombs though.
We're okay though.
Oh, they blew up.
That's good.
They made... Oh, shit.
Nope.
We need to grab some lifesteal.
Holy fuck.
Who the fuck was that?
Oh.
The Onigiris.
What even are...
What's the fan name of the Onigiri?
I don't know much about like, the JP mascots.
Um...
I don't know the names of all the JP mascots.
The Mogu Mogu?
The Oni...
Okay...
Oh, fuck!
Okay, sorry.
I looked at chat.
Alright.
Hahaha.
I'm sorry.
There's way too many things going on.
Oh no.
Oh, how am I supposed to go through the halls when there's so many of them?
Oh god.
Please!
No!
Okay, it's fine.
We're fine.
We actually dodged that.
That's insane that I managed to dodge that.
Hahaha.
Exactly.
This is why we have speed.
Look, I told you we didn't need that upgrade, chat.
Jesus Christ!
Why are you so tanky?
Oh no, now they're angry.
Oh no, what did I do?
Hahaha.
Why are you angry?
What did I do?
We have...
Okay.
I can't go there.
Alright, we're gonna get more black licorice.
Oh god, please.
We need more black licorice.
Yeah.
I'm trying to get closer to the...
To the fucking boss!
There's just too many things!
Okay, here.
Alright.
We gotta...
We gotta be able to kill the...
Oh no, get out of here.
No.
Please, just let me fucking kill him!
Oh, there's an arrow!
I'm heading over!
Don't worry!
Oh, nice.
But first, let me grab this.
Please not Halu.
Yes!
We got maxed food.
Oh, you're gonna die.
Okay, arrow time.
Arrow time!
Just...
Woo!
Maxed book.
Arrow time.
What the fuck was chopping down from here?
Oh, more cats.
More cats.
Please.
Get me through here.
Where the fuck is the arrow?
It's above me?
Oh, it's above me.
What the fuck is that?
A crowbar?
Oh, knockback.
Nice.
Yes.
I always need knockback.
Okay, now I'm...
Now I don't know.
This is actually the worst...
Oh, how did I get out of that?
Okay, nevermind.
I'm just gaming.
I'm just gaming because I'm naturally gifted, not because of the choice of the talent.
Okay, here we go.
It's not because of who I picked.
It's because I'm just naturally good at this game.
Oh.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
Knock back help... no no no!
No no no!
Alright,
which one?
One, three ish... one, two, four... I see a lot of...
I see a lot of twos or threes.
Is three actually good?
Three or four?
Okay, we'll do three.
Guys, I don't know what you're talking about.
Oh my god!
What's going on?
Oh okay, okay.
I always thought that thing was gonna come down on me.
Okay, please.
It's literally right there.
Let me grab that chicken.
Apply this stamp to this weapon.
I don't know what it does, but I'll do it.
Oh, I got wings too!
Decrease damage of the wa- oh wait.
No, right?
Yeah, I'm not gonna... no.
It says decrease the damage.
Wait, dead in ten seconds?
Why?
So... what do you mean?
What do you mean?
What do you mean by... what do you mean?
What happens in ten seconds?
What?
Wait... wait, wait, what happened?
What happens in ten seconds?
One... oh no.
Alright, it's gonna happen in three seconds.
It's okay, I have all- it's- oh, I got big!
Okay.
Oh god.
I'm running as fast as I can.
I don't know what she does.
I don't- oh, it's a flamethrower!
It's a flamethrower.
I know what she does.
Wait, Frozer!
I'm Frozer!
Okay.
Oh god.
Oh god, please.
Please, I'm so fast.
I'm so fucking fa- It's okay.
If I go in a circle!
Big baby.
Big fucking baby is here.
Alright.
It's okay.
The circle's trying- Oh!
Alright.
I'm gaming.
I knew it!
The circle's trying!
Just like real life!
I'm gaming!
The freeze clutch!
We're not doing- I- I could read holo!
I can read!
Alright.
Okay, what do we do?
Two?
Guys!
I can read!
Alright.
Uh...
One.
No, two for- okay, two for the- Oh, the collab.
Alright.
Nice.
What is this?
I swear to god.
Okay, axe.
Do I take it?
I don't think I have an axe.
I don't.
I have one empty slot.
I think the last empty slot.
Or do I sell it?
Max out?
No.
Take?
Alright, we'll take it.
I think it's good for collabs, right?
That's fucking right.
Dude, fuck that person that was like, you're not gonna survive the halftime, boss.
Told you.
Pure skill.
Okay, four.
Alright.
Alright, now we just have to live for ten more minutes.
I feel like...
I think we're set for life now.
We're set.
We're set for life.
We can do this.
Oh yeah, the axe with the...
The axe with the book.
With the black licorice.
Because I love having...
I love using...
I love to cut trees and eat black licorice at the same time.
Aight.
I guess we'll try, we'll upgrade axe so we can collab later.
Axe time.
We have so many too.
Jesus Christ, who keeps giving you the shields?
They're expensive!
Oh my God, there's a collab!
Oh, there's an upgrade, there's an admin!
Okay, we're fine.
We gotta grab the...
I'm gonna go with the Anvil though.
Nice.
Uhhh... axe.
Uhhh...
Where's the axe?
There's no more axe.
Uhhh...
Let's see.
One or two?
Two?
Alright.
Two.
Uhhh...
I guess we do the...
The plug, right?
What a fucking sentence.
Or two?
Alright.
Uhhh...
Oh my god, okay.
Alright.
Oh my gosh, there's so many.
Which one do we do here?
One makes more DPS.
Yes, we do the plug.
Alright.
Headphones or...
One or two?
Weapon... Okay, I'll do...
I'll do... There's more ones.
Upgrade!
What do we upgrade?
I don't even know which one to upgrade.
There's so many.
Do we upgrade our scythe even more?
Axe?
Who?
Axe.
Okay, I see more axes.
Alright, upgrade.
Nice.
Oh!
What's that?
Once per second, one attacks... weapon hacks may heal a random amount...
Wait!
Lifesteal!
Lifesteal is always good!
Right?
Yeah!
I'm gonna do it.
I'm gonna get the lifesteal.
I know lifesteal is always...
What the fuck is this?
Adds one additional shot to ranged multi-shot weapons.
Does not affect melee weapon.
Wait, but I am a melee weapon.
How do I sell this?
Can I upgrade this for free?
Wait, can I strengthen?
Uhhh... upgrade...
Okay, upgrade.
Upgrade, strengthen, confirm.
Nice!
Holy shit!
I love not thinking for myself.
It's so nice.
This is why I'm a streamer now.
I'm pretty sure becoming a streamer has actually made me more stupid.
Because I have no free will anymore.
That is the risk you take.
Head M4.
Empty.
Let chat decide everything for you.
Oh my gosh.
You like the movie Wall-E?
And then like the humans are on those chairs.
But like...
And the robots take care of them.
That's gonna be me.
It's like, what do I do chat?
Oh, hey!
What's this?
Crit up.
That's the dream right there.
I don't understand why they would want to go back to earth.
Why would they need to go back to earth?
What's the point?
Replace?
Swap crowbar?
Okay.
Swap...
Oh.
Swap with...
Swap.
Alright, here we go.
Swap two?
Which one?
Do we replace the crowbar or the chicken?
The chicken saved my life!
Oh, that's a good one.
Crowbar is good?
Okay, I'll swap then.
Alright.
Alright, here we go.
I swapped.
Alright, we're good.
And then we upgrade.
What do we upgrade?
Strengthen lifesteal?
Crit?
Crit or lifesteal?
Okay, I'll strengthen lifesteal.
Nice.
Alright, here we go.
We're good.
Wait, whose mascot is that?
Oh my god!
Collab!
Okay.
Axe and black licorice.
There you go.
Do we...
Uh...
Is that the collab we want?
Eating black licorice while we cut down some trees?
Yeah?
Alright.
Nice.
Okay.
God, I love to cut trees.
Alright, here we go.
We're doing pretty well!
I mean, we're...
This is like the furthest we've ever gone.
I haven't seen any like bosses in a while too.
Oh god, where are they running from?
Who are you running from?
Oh...
Dodge!
Easy.
Alright.
Over here we go.
I feel like fan mascots are like...
It's like mini Sanrio.
Alright.
Increase rate...
Oh, I don't know any... Okay.
Death or energy drink or glow stick?
Are any of these good?
Death?
Okay, death.
Alright.
I feel like fan mascots, they're like...
Mini Sanrio characters if you think about it.
It's so smart!
It actually is.
Because you have anime girls and...
Who the fuck are you?
Who's fan mascot is that?
Where are the blue flames?
I think it's better than death.
Oh, really?
I feel like I haven't seen these guys a lot.
Often.
The comments.
Yeah, but it's like...
You get anime girls.
Cute anime girls.
And then you also get Sanrio characters.
Oh, it's not official?
They're like unofficial designs?
Do we get...
I guess we can upgrade the tail.
Who's coming out from here?
Because I don't see these guys often.
On social media.
I get my news on Twitter.
Doki is blonde.
Likes Deforestation.
Wonderbread man supported.
No, not Wonderbread.
Wonderbread man.
You know, I would not oppose to have the Wonderbread guy be a... like Oshii-ing me.
Because that guy...
The amount of money he fucking spends on fucking Wonderbread art...
It's like...
It's a lot.
Bro!
He's... He's like...
He's an oiler.
For sure.
True.
And like...
If...
If the risk is just, you know, talking about Wonderbread ever so often...
Like, I feel like that's like an exchange I'm willing to make.
Like, it's just Wonderbread.
Like, it's just...
Okay, increase.
I have... I already have that anyway.
He's a neurosurgeon?
Uh...
I guess...
I guess I'll upgrade the glasses since I...
I have the glasses on, right?
He's a fucking neurosurgeon?
Okay, this is...
He has to be normal in real life.
So this is his, like, outlet.
Like, I imagine, like, you know, since you're a neurosurgeon you can't be like...
Like, you know, a freak.
So like...
I swear, a lot of, like, the people with, like, who are like...
freaks on the internet with, like, the craziest fucking, like, shit.
Like...
They, like...
They put on the mask.
You know?
They, like, you know, like, online is where it stays.
Like, he needs an outlet.
So that's why he's able to afford...
Imagine your fucking neurosurgeon is the Wonderbread guy.
So for those who are wondering what the fuck is the Wonderbread guy.
So the... Okay, do we...
Do we get fan beam or, like, the glasses?
Do we... Like, you're about to get, like, the most, like...
You're about to get, like, the most intense heart sur... Uh, wait, where...
It's like a neurosurgeon has a heart surgery.
Sorry.
Wrong area.
Okay.
You're about to go into surgery and...
And, uh...
And, like, it's like some fucking 10% survival rate or something.
And this is your doc... Like...
And then... And then...
Your doctor is the Wonderbread guy.
Like, I don't know.
I... I mean, if he's a really good doctor, I feel like I shouldn't care.
If he's really good at his job, like, it should be fine.
Right?
Like, as long as he's really good at his job.
Alright.
But anyway, for those who are confused about, like, what the fuck is the Wonderbread guy.
Okay, this is like old internet lore.
But he used to be, like...
Oh my god.
He could be a better doctor now.
He could be, like, a better doctor because it's, like, years now if you think about it.
It's been...
It's been fucking years.
And he has to have improved his doctoring.
So, like, anyway...
Sorry.
I keep getting off track because I was supposed to explain to people who don't know...
who don't know who the Wonderbread guy is.
So, the Wonderbread guy...
Basically, he...
Okay, wait.
Uh...
I guess, uh... I'll increase that.
He basically commissions people to draw, like, women buying Wonderbread.
And they're always blonde.
Like, he has this very weird obsession with, like, Wonder Bread.
And he just commissions women... Like, artwork of women.
Um...
Blonde women drawing, like, drawings.
And they're all just buying...
buying bread.
Oh, and... and deforestation.
Yeah, and cutting down trees.
And cutting down trees because he hates trees, I guess.
Um...
And that's what gets him going.
That's,
like, exactly what, like, makes him, like, really happy in life.
Um...
But, like, if he's good at his job...
I feel like... Okay, if he's, like, really good at his job, like, and it's, like, life or death...
Like, I would... Like, I don't mind if he operates on me.
Hehehehehehe!
He should, like, have a card and be like, you've just...
I was saved by the Wonderbread guy.
But anyway...
Anyway, um...
Anyway, there's a lot of...
Like, there...
I feel like a lot of them are, like, really normal people outside of the internet.
And then when you found... find out... Holy shit!
When you...
Okay, when you find out...
Like, when you find the mask that they take off, it's actually crazy.
It's like those people that commission.
Those, like... Oh my god!
I used to be on DeviantArt.
Like, cause I was an artist.
So, like, you know...
Like, all... There was only one place to go.
It was either Tumblr or DeviantArt or both.
Or other websites.
Hehehehehehe!
Hehehehe!
Or other websites for different categories.
Um... But, like, this would always pop up in the trending on DeviantArt.
And...
And... I follow him on Twitter and from what I've seen, he's actually very nice.
Locke, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Like, it's just... It's just, like, what he's into.
Hehehehehe!
It's just... Hahaha!
Hahaha!
Like, he has to be a really nice guy.
It's just that he's into some really freaky shit!
Um... But, like, there was this, like, one thing that kept, like, showing up on, like, DeviantArt, like, front page.
And I was... Oh my god!
Oh my go... Okay, okay, I was scared what that could entail.
Like, when I heard the That shit, like, freaks me out.
Oh my god!
I can't see!
There's too many things!
Anyway!
Anyway, do you guys know, like, this thing called... What's it called?
Bimbo-mification?
Like, where, like, people would draw... Like, apparently you... Someone wrote a new... Wrote an actual, like, news article about it.
Because it was such a weird trend.
And...
Hahaha!
It was...
It was such a weird fad slash trend.
Because... Wait, what is that?
What is that?
Do I have to kill it before it explodes?
Like, what does that mean?
Do I have to kill this before it explodes?
I'm 18 seconds!
Oh god.
Okay, I'm trying.
I'm trying.
I didn't realize I have to kill this before it explodes.
Oh, thank god.
Okay.
Holy shit.
Okay, as I was saying...
As I was saying...
Where was I?
Um... Okay.
So, basically, what that is...
Was that... Apparently, artists made a shitload of money because, like, there was an article written about it.
And they, like, talked about how much they made.
Like, charged for, like, those types of... Those types of, like, art commissions.
And they made fucking a bank.
Is this it?
Are these two the combinations?
Or is that...
Woo!
Dragonfire!
Um... And basically, it is, like...
Oh my gosh, look at that.
Like, it's like...
A nerdy girl turning into a bimbo.
It'll be like, first stage, she's reading a li... She has glasses on and is reading a library book.
Second stage, she starts reading easier books.
And then, like, the...
Like, she starts reading picture books.
It's so fucking...
It's so...
Stop talking...
Okay.
And then...
Um...
And then she just... She just...
Oh my god!
Is that Saf's song?
And then she just starts reading, like... Like...
I guess, like...
Dumber and dumber books?
Like...
It's so fucking weird.
Until she's, like...
Until she stops reading.
No!
I swear I got perms for this game!
Sessa!
Oh god, we gotta... We gotta get rid of...
I swear!
We got perms!
Okay, here we go.
Until she becomes a...
Until she cannot think for herself, i.e.
me.
I mean, streaming is sort of like...
A big publication!
Okay.
Um...
What do we do?
Two?
Or four?
Increase lab?
I'll do four, okay.
That's fine.
I swear, apparently...
I accidentally wasted...
I accidentally wasted it for...
Oh no!
What is that?
Ahaha!
No!
Not Toho!
We were so close!
I'm so bad at Toho!
My one weakness!
Toho!
Meta.
Please.
Hahaha!
Ah!
That's meta!
Iris is meta, right?
Who else is meta?
Okay.
I heard like Mumei is meta too, right?
Oh my god, I'll never get Mumei!
I got meta!
Hahaha!
Okay, nice.
We have meta now.
Alright.
Oh, I have like different outfits!
I wanna be Santa.
Merry Christmas!
Hahaha!
Everyone is meta.
Alright.
Okay, I feel like...
We can totally...
Like, how do I recommend upgrades?
Okay, where do I shop?
Is it... How do I upgrade that?
Is it like...
Oh, stat upgrade!
Hahaha!
There's another stat!
Hey guys!
I don't know if you guys know this, but there is another tab for stats!
I can't believe I haven't upgraded stats once!
I...
I can't believe...
I... I can't believe it!
I... That was the one...
I was playing everything at by...
By...
Default!
Wow!
No wonder everybody was like...
Doki!
Stats!
Guys, I didn't realize...
I didn't realize there was a whole other tab!
That's fucking crazy!
Hahaha!
Nice!
Guys, there was a whole other tab!
Did you guys know that?
Oh my god!
You know what?
Maybe I do, baby!
Hahaha!
Um...
Justice!
Thank you for the Aka Aka Supa!
Thank you, thank you!
Hey, is it too late to see you play Phasmophobia?
Thank you for the Aka Aka Supa!
Hahaha!
Maybe one day...
Is Phasmophobia still popular?
Okay, what do we get?
These are all new stuff.
Uh...
Time for money!
It's two hundred and...
Four?
Alright, four.
Guys...
I just can't believe it.
There was a whole new other level.
Hahaha!
Who?
I told you!
Streaming is like modern day...
Hahaha!
It's... it's modern day!
Um... Sam, thank you for the fifty gifted chips!
Thank you, thank you!
Really appreciate it!
Thank you so much!
Uh... alright, we'll do...
Do we stop?
Ah!
I read chat!
Alright, it's fine.
We're fine.
I just gotta kill some deadbeats real fast and the shrimps.
Boop!
Nice.
Uh...
I guess we upgrade fully on...
Fully on her weapon, right?
There's a pity section for the gacha by the way.
Ten pulls equals one redeem of character.
Oh, I love pity.
This is exactly why I don't do gacha.
I try to avoid gacha game is because I'm worried I'm actually gonna find a gacha game that I'm really gonna like.
I...
Hahaha!
Like, I'm so scared that like eventually even though like I try not to be invested in... I don't do gacha game is because my one fear is that I'll actually get invested in gacha games and then I'm gonna lose all my money.
That is my one fear.
Cause like gacha is...
Hahaha!
It's like there's two things that can like be scary.
Um...
Being invested in gacha games or being invested in gambling.
That is like the worst fears to have.
Because you know your wallet is not going to like it.
Your wallet is not going to like it.
And then the worst thing about gacha is like the game will eventually shut down one day.
And then like... Okay, hope increase crit hit.
Cause like the game is going to eventually one day be shut down with all the servers and stuff.
So then you have to think like, oh my god all that money.
Hahaha!
My PNGs!
And then because I already am invested in Fortnite skins and like I personally have already spent like at least a thousand dollars on Fortnite skins.
And like that scares me.
You know what?
Fuck it.
We'll get more enemies.
Like this should be fine.
There's more money.
Right?
This is... Iris is like the... My wives!
Hahaha!
And husbandos!
Um... Okay, we're getting hollow now because like we can take it.
You know what?
Fuck it!
I ain't scared!
I have meta!
Hahaha!
It is...
Um... A lot.
Wait, what does...
What does my hope... Oh, it's a bomb.
Okay.
That's a bomb.
Alright, let's see.
Grab like her or...
Oh, nice.
That's good.
What is this?
Uh... I guess I'll upgrade.
I'm not gonna upgrade hollow.
Hahaha!
It's the greed time!
Okay, never... No, that's fine.
I don't need more greed.
Alright!
Other than three.
What else?
Who?
Okay.
Guys, we need to max out our shit before we get more greedy.
Guys!
We need to be stronger before we can get greedy.
Okay, wait.
What's that?
Oh, it's just deadbeats.
It's just a few of them.
Yeah, that's what I'm afraid of.
Hahaha!
I'm afraid of like actually getting really invested in gacha and that...
And then like...
Because I already have a Fortnite issue.
And then I have to think about having a...
Uh...
Hahaha!
Gacha issue!
Alright.
Fuck, I didn't read what she does.
So I hope it's not...
Anything that would fuck me over.
It is dangerous when you have like...
Your main gacha game.
It's so dangerous.
It's so... Oh my god!
No, I can't.
That's NDA asking.
Hahaha!
I was gonna say...
Okay, I was like curious.
Cause I was like...
Cause you know like...
Okay, not getting three.
I was thinking about like...
You know like... Oh my god.
Like those casino sponsors.
Oh my... They get paid so much money.
Hahaha!
Like it's actually crazy.
But obviously I can't say what...
How much...
Hahaha!
It's actually crazy.
Oh!
Okay, it'll be fine.
We'll be fine.
We'll find a burger.
Hahaha!
Uh...
No fucking course I...
Of course I didn't get...
I was curious cause I was like...
I was like how much do they get paid for that?
And I'm like...
Oh my...
Which makes sense because like...
Like if you own a casino...
You have to make so much money.
Because like...
Cause like...
It's Las Vegas.
Like...
My tax will look pretty.
There's no... Nice.
That's all I want.
As long as it looks pretty.
Hahaha!
The best upgrade there is.
Cause like...
Like...
Las Vegas rent in general...
Has to be fucking insane.
Because like...
You know like the spear?
I talked about this before.
But like...
Uh... I guess we do half angel?
Or the RGB meta?
Or...
One?
Okay.
So like...
Oh god.
My hands were off my keyboard.
Cause like the spear...
In Las Vegas...
You know like... I forgot.
Like...
For like 30 seconds of advertising...
On the spear...
Is like what?
Like $20,000?
It has to be more.
Is it more?
I don't remember.
Hahaha!
It's more right?
It's not profit.
Okay.
They're making zero profit by the way.
Off of the spear.
It cost a lot.
It was more than $30,000.
I remember I ranted about it.
It's not $30,000.
It was like $100,000.
Is it $100,000?
Or some shit for like 30 seconds?
It's like so much.
By the way, the spear right now makes zero profit.
Hahaha!
It would take them like...
I think like 10 to 20 years.
Before they actually see real profit.
Yeah.
$450k per day.
If you wanna be on the spear...
It would take $450,000 a day to be on the spear.
Oh god.
Bomb time.
Hahaha!
But it's so cool though.
That is true.
But it's also $450,000.
Hahaha!
Yeah like...
Okay.
Here's to give context.
So... Oh chicken!
Okay.
Here's to give context.
Um...
To have like an advertisement...
On the...
On the Tokyo...
Oh god.
Please.
Hahaha!
The Tokyo like... Subways?
Uh... Oh no.
What do we get?
Alright.
What did I get?
I didn't...
I didn't get an upgrade.
Okay.
I don't know what upgrade I got chat.
I don't know.
I stopped.
Okay.
I'm focused.
Doki on the spear fun.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I don't know what I got.
Hahaha!
Oh shit!
Oh my god!
It's super chat time!
Guys!
Oh my god!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you!
Hahaha!
Alright.
What do we got here?
Pay up.
Super chat.
Yeah baby!
Oh my god!
Blue supers!
And green supers!
Glory.
Okay.
What was I saying?
To give context.
Oh my... Okay.
Guys.
Give me a second.
I need to like clear this up first.
Yes!
Xander!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Mike!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Okay.
Where was I?
Wait.
Who's Xander?
Did I just made up a name?
Oh no.
There you go!
I was like...
Hahaha!
There you are Xander!
Got you!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Alright.
Renard.
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
You know I'm confident.
I'm so fucking confident now.
Okay.
Oh my god!
Level 2 super chat!
Level 3!
What's a level 3 super chat?
Hahaha!
What does a... Oh my god!
What does a level 3 super chat look like?
Increase lava...
Someone say super chat time!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Shock!
Okay.
Wait.
Speed up.
Lava.
Band-aid.
Every heal 10 HPI for 3 seconds until 80% of...
Alright!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Super chat time!
Alright.
Let's see.
3 or 4...
Oh my god!
Luch!
Thank you for the Akka super!
Thank you!
The super chat!
Alright.
3.
Oh no.
What is this?
The first target this weapon hit is marked.
The marked target will see... Oh!
Nice!
Wait.
That's good.
That's great.
Free super chat!
Yes.
When you get to level 4 super chat time, all super chats become free.
That is my goal.
We need to hit level 4 super chat so it can be free and then we can bankrupt YouTube!
It's like Amazon Prime.
When you subscribe to your favorite Twitch streamer for free.
Um...
Throw 2 lava buckets.
Super chat time!
David, thank you for the Akka super!
Thank you!
3 or 2.
I guess I'll do...
I'll do 2 then.
Nice.
Level 3.
Every time I look away.
Oh my god.
Wait.
He's gold.
Why he gold?
Is he stupid?
We're at level 3 right now!
We're almost there!
Okay.
We're gonna grab this.
Increase crit.
I guess we'll do hope level 3, right?
Oh!
He's marked!
That's why.
I'm stupid chat.
I'm stupid.
The goal is to have Doki.
Let Doki... Oh my god!
We're at level 4!
Guys!
All super chats are now free!
Um... Asterisk.
Um... Legally...
Legal wise, all super chats are not free right now.
That is a joke.
Um... If you accidentally delete... If you accidentally try to super chat me all your money and your bank calls me, you cannot use the excuse that, oh, I was watching a Doki bird stream and she told me that level 4 super chats are now free, so I'm exempt from a no.
Legally speaking, it is a joke.
But level 4 super chats!
That means free super chats!
Let's go!
Oh hey!
What's this?
Attacks have a potential to cause an explosion that hits nearby targets.
For 30% of the weapons... Ooh!
Wait, that's good.
Wait, wait, wait.
That's good.
I was like, what the is?
What is the 4 I want?
Alright.
Oh.
This is not good.
This is not good!
This is not getting good!
I'm gonna run through.
I'm just gonna run through.
I'm trying to get to the arrow.
I think I took too many holos.
Guys, I think I took too many holos.
Oh my god, it's totally free!
Alright, attacks have 3% chance to hit... Bolo coins.
Oh.
Okay, I'm sorry.
We don't need RGBs anymore.
I'm sorry, RGB.
Oh, I should sell it!
Wait, I forgot.
I can sell this.
Oh, I can strengthen this.
Wait, where do we...
Uh, freeze?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Look, I got a freeze!
Look at that!
It's working!
Other people are getting free super chats too!
Look at that!
Guys, it's working!
It was a joke, guys.
Just so you guys remember, this is a joke.
Okay, we'll do elite bucket.
Too late, I already spent all of my savings.
Thank you for the super chat.
Magenta soup.
Thank you.
Kisser, is it possible to go beyond?
Dad, thank you for the akka soupa!
Thank you, thank you.
Did someone say free soupas?
Thank you for the akka soupa.
Thank you.
Is there a level five?
Can we go even further?
What the fuck would a level five soupa be?
You just give me your credit card.
This is...
Level five.
We go beyond.
There is a level five?
Oh my god.
Level five?
You call your bank and then transfer your bank ownership...
bank account ownership.
That is...
That is level five.
Oh my god!
Guys!
It's here!
Oh my god.
Level five.
The rich!
Alright, let's get that lava.
Oh my god.
I can't believe it.
Think of all the interest rates we're gonna get together.
There's a level five as a blank check.
Level five.
You start a trust fund on your doki's name.
Holy shit.
I'm still alive!
Free soupas, let's go!
Thank you for the magenta soupa.
Thank you.
It's okay.
I'm okay guys.
Look at that.
I'm gaming.
Iris is truly meta.
Oh my god.
Iris, I knew...
I knew Santa would not let me down.
I knew it.
I knew Santa would never let me down!
Get over here.
Get o- Oh!
Oh my god.
Oh wait, what did I get?
Oh!
Haste?
Reduce the time?
Wait.
The first...
What do I get rid of?
Do I get rid of or do I upgrade?
Should I just use this to upgrade?
Do I just use this to upgrade guys?
Doki, where is my wallet?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Alright, thank you for the fifty gift and chips.
Okay.
We'll beef that up.
Jesus.
We are so strong right now.
Okay, now I don't know what to upgrade.
They're all new.
Uh...
No!
I just saw upgrade so I got... Inject super chat into my veins.
Man, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I ruined it!
No!
I got too greedy!
I saw... I went level five and never looked back.
You've changed, Doki.
Ever since you went to level five super chat, you've changed.
All those bank accounts changed you.
Alright, let's see.
I got so greedy.
I got way too greedy.
The greed!
I can't.
I drank the halloo.
What even is halloo?
I...
Alright.
Wait, do we do horn or bucket?
I missed the old Doki.
One.
Okay.
Oh my god, Jesus.
I guess we'll go full bucket.
And then horn or crit?
Chat.
Horn or corn?
Horn is great.
No need horn.
Horn three.
I'll do horn then.
Horn.
Oh my god, there's so much more horn.
Oh fuck!
Okay.
Follow me.
All healing is doubled.
Oh, credit card.
Cost of enhancing is reduced, but uh... I guess spider cooking or upgrade my stuff?
Credit card or spider cooking?
Alright.
Oh my god, there's still more.
We'll go bucket since we're almost there.
Stuff five times in a row in one...
Jesus Christ, I did not upgrade.
I did not...
I was not picking up anything.
I can't upgrade greed!
Oh no.
Big boy is coming.
Uhhhh...
Can I get rid of marking?
Should I swap marking for this?
I'm gonna swap and then...
Strengthen greed.
Greed.
Upgrade.
Okay, upgrade.
Strength.
Alright, nice.
We have... we have bomb.
We have bomb.
Go go go go bomb.
Go.
Go go bomb.
You got this.
Alright, bomb is gone.
Woah!
Okay.
Alright, I'm getting damaged so fucking hard right now.
Is this the half time boss?
This is.
This is the half time boss.
Holy shit.
Bro, he's raining money for me though.
He's actually raining money.
It's raining money.
Let's go.
This is the power of level four super chats.
This is...
I feel so strong.
I've changed.
Okay.
Let's grab the box.
What do I get?
Nice.
We need that.
What happened to you Doki?
Ever since... what is this?
Weapon hits have... uh...
Oh, I'm on level five.
Sorry.
The greed caught me so fast that I don't even know what level I'm on.
I'm drunk off all the bank accounts.
There's so many.
Okay, swap.
And then we upgrade.
Uh... we upgrade.
Bomb, right?
Greed level...
We swap, upgrade three.
Okay.
Nice.
Alright, nice.
Oh my god.
There was this conversation earlier about the fucking... Okay, I was gonna say, to give context as to how...
how fucking crazy $400,000 is... like $450,000 for the sphere.
It is $20,000 for one day, by the way.
The sphere is one day.
$400,000 $250,000 and then for one week on... I think it was at...
in Shibuya Station in Tokyo is $20,000 for one week.
That's how expensive...
I'm heading to the arrow!
Look at all these rats!
I have to kill all the rats first!
Okay, let me get sick.
Alright, what do we upgrade?
Here we go.
We'll upgrade the...
We'll upgrade the blast.
Alright, and then...
Oh my god, I got weapon will fire.
There is no other effect!
It will fire backwards!
Okay, then...
What do we upgrade here?
Um...
Speed!
Thank you for the five gifted ships!
Thank you!
Strengthen two?
Okay, strengthen.
Alright.
Is there any more arrows?
Okay, there's no more arrows.
We should be good.
Holy shit!
We're so fucking strong right now.
Stage one is Ashley, baby.
Alright.
We haven't got like the...
the collab stuff yet though.
I need to grab the collabs.
Now I know why people can stream hours of this game.
I watch like the VOD, like see the VOD timestamp of this game and it's like uh, five plus hours.
I understand now.
I understand.
I get it now, chat.
I figured it out.
This is very addicting.
Guys, I know my directions!
I'm heading down for once in my life.
I figured out where to go.
Hahaha!
Wait, we're at two hours?
I've been playing this game for two hours now?
Holy fuck!
Jesus, okay.
Okay.
This might be a problem.
Hahaha!
I did not feel the two hours.
Not gonna... wait, is this good?
Attacks have 20% chance at uh...
Let's see.
Yeah, I can...
I should upgrade this.
Alright.
Two upgrade, right?
Is that... uh...
Alright, well...
Because I didn't know if I should...
Oh my god, I'm so rich!
I'm so rich!
I can finally upgrade...
You know, I remember when you guys kept yelling at me to upgrade stats.
Like, when you guys would yell stats, and I thought that you meant like the talent...
The talent has really good stats.
And that's what I thought you meant when you guys kept yelling stats at me.
And not because of...
Hahaha!
When in reality, you were telling me to purchase my stat upgrades.
And...
I couldn't tell.
Yelling... Yeah, I was like, what's the context?
I was like, why does my chat keep yelling stats at me?
I don't understand.
Why would they keep yelling that?
Is it because the talents are really... have really good stats in general?
Like, what is the context?
Hahaha!
Where the fuck is the context?
Alright.
We'll do... We'll max up the cooking.
You know what?
Am I sure about this?
I am so sure.
Bro, this is fucking baby shit.
I'm so sure.
Alright.
Do we get bandage?
We're doing it.
We are max... We're...
We're so fucking... Look at that.
$6000 now.
I have like so many bank accounts in my... Hahaha!
I have... I have so many bank accounts now.
Hahaha!
Don't...
I'm gonna do it!
What's the worst that's gonna happen?
Hahaha!
Alright.
Now this is all new.
I don't know what to get.
I'm locked in.
I am full on hollow now.
Look at the... I'm fucking drunk with power.
I'm a level 5 super chatter.
Why is chat yelling?
Are they stupid?
I don't think it was a super chat.
They...
Thank you.
Alright.
One or four.
Uhh... We'll do...
We'll do four.
Okay.
What's the worst that could happen?
Anyway.
I'm so much money.
Like, come on.
We're gonna do... Nothing!
Where the fuck is the collab anvil?
Alright.
What do we upgrade, chat?
I already upgraded the blast.
I know, but I have to...
I have to kill... I have to get the one up.
I need to go up before I can go down.
Chat, I need to go up before I can go down.
Wait, did I just accidentally pay for that?
Alright.
Yeah.
Oh my gosh.
No regrets.
Wait, what's that?
Peaky, peeky?
Wait, is this good?
I don't know if I should get this.
I haven't grabbed this before.
Wait, grab this or nah?
Take it?
It's called investment?
Is it good?
Take it.
Okay.
I believe.
I trust you guys.
There's no way you guys would fuck me over.
Unlike all the other times you guys fucked me over.
This time, there's no way you guys would fuck me over.
Okay.
Compared to all the other times you guys tried to fuck me over, there's no way this time it'll work.
Uh.
We would never.
It was not one guy!
I literally see!
Two for collab?
Two?
Okay.
Alright.
What do we get, chat?
What do we upgrade?
It's not one guy if it was multiple guys.
It could be multiple one guys though.
Uh.
Two?
Or three?
Upgrade two and three?
Okay.
We'll do...
We'll do two upgrade first.
Alright.
Nice.
We're good now.
Alright.
And then...
What do we get here?
Uh.
Do we upgrade the pikki or the bomb?
I think it was multiple two guys.
You need level seven weapons for collab?
Thank you, super chat master.
Thank you.
Three?
Okay.
This is fine.
There is so many sparkles up here.
Jesus Christ.
Oh no.
What's coming down?
Okay.
Oh my god!
I need to...
I need to get rid of the...
We need...
There's way too much flashes.
Okay.
Is it the visual effects?
Let's see.
Oh my god.
Yeah.
There we go.
There's like... That was like way too many flashes.
That was like insane.
Alright.
There we go.
The numbers!
What do they mean?
What do the numbers mean?
Can I fix my settings?
I don't remember.
Alright.
Wait.
What if I do damage?
What effects is this?
Was it...
Yeah.
It was.
Let's get rid of that.
No!
The numbers!
We're fine.
Now it's not flashing anymore.
Alright.
Let's increase damage by 5% for each weapon.
Okay.
We maxed everything.
Yeah.
We don't... We can sell this.
Nice.
Alright.
There's another arrow below me.
Oh no.
Okay.
We'll grab this.
Oh no.
I'm trying to go down.
Oh my
god!
They're so fast!
Guys!
Okay.
We're fine.
Oh.
Okay.
I forgot the...
The Halu shit.
I forgot the Halu shit.
Uh...
Three.
Okay.
We're gonna...
This is bad.
I should not have... Guys.
I should not...
Guys.
I realized that maybe... I should not have went full in on Halu.
I should not have went full in on Halu.
Oh my god!
I did it!
Magnet!
There's so many!
There's so many.
It's gonna take forever to get the magnet chat.
Please.
Oh god.
Oh!
Fucking don't go full Halu!
Guys.
Never go full Halu.
I made my mistakes.
Guys.
Never go full Halu.
I can't believe it.
When the upgrade said don't do it.
Why did I do it?
Who would have thought?
When it says don't do it.
You should not do it.
I can't believe it.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Two.
Uh...
Two bombs.
Okay.
Oh my god.
It's okay.
We got the box.
Axe?
Did we pick up the axe?
Should we pick up the axe?
Always go full Halu.
Yeah?
Drop?
Okay.
Yes.
I see more takes than drops.
Alright.
What is this?
Oh.
I got another axe.
Nice.
Okay.
We don't need to take that magnet.
We already have like way too many magnets anyway.
We have more than enough magnets chat.
Alright.
It's fine.
It is.
Oh my god.
It might not be fine.
It might not be FINE!
Oh my god.
Holy shit.
We're okay.
I'm following the arrows!
Oh my god.
Three or four.
Four?
Okay.
Uh...
We might as well grab the axe.
Okay.
There is a hammer.
I don't know what the hammer does.
What did that do?
What did I do?
I just walked over it.
And I don't know what happened.
What the fuck does the hammer do?
What did it do?
I can't tell.
It's a super intense... a super collab?
Oh.
Okay.
Nothing.
Yes you are.
Hello there.
I can't believe.
The devs didn't warn me about HALO.
I can't believe it.
Why didn't they warn me?
How could they not do that.
I can't believe it.
Okay.
Let's just keep going.
Green over here.
Let's grab the green first.
What is the green?
Attacks have 20% chance to reduce attack and defense of targets but...
We don't need that, right?
We don't need that.
Why would it... it's like the bicycle meme.
You know, when you're riding the bicycle and...
And then it's like, upgrade Halu.
And I was like, why would the devs do this?
Did I stick the stick into my bicycle?
How could the devs do this to me?
Oh no.
I'm trying.
Okay.
We're gonna try and figure out how to get to the other side.
Oh my god, there's the anvil but I can't do anything about it!
There's a trumpet too!
There's too many things on my screen.
Alright, nice.
We got...
Okay.
We can...
No, we have to save our ultimate!
Let's see.
What do we do?
Swap to?
For the projectile stamp?
Or sell it?
Or do we wait for...
Swap to.
Okay, swap.
Confirm.
And then...
Strengthen.
Yeah.
There you go.
Okay, and then we're gonna grab this anvil.
Let's see.
Do we get...
I guess we can...
And then we'll do...
The...
Yeah.
Alright, we gotta grab the trumpet.
Give me a sec!
Oh my god!
Holy shit, he's so strong!
Okay, we're gonna...
Okay, we're so slow.
We are so slow right now.
Oh my god.
We actually need to be faster.
You're not the trumpet!
Oh my god.
You're not the trumpet.
Alright.
I'm gonna upgrade.
Wait, is it max?
I already maxed it out?
Okay, we're gonna drop...
I'm gonna drop this for now.
We get to get the trumpet.
Max, okay.
Oh my god.
We're so fucked.
We are so fucked.
I can't get the trumpet!
There's so many people!
I'm so slow!
Oh no!
Oh, please have a speed somewhere!
Okay.
Max.
I maxed it out.
There's the bomb!
There's the club!
Okay.
Alright.
What do we replace?
Swap two.
Okay.
We swap two.
And then...
Wait, do we...
Don't even...
Wait, do we swap two?
Okay.
Don't keep...
What do we...
What is this?
What's that?
There's no...
You made me risk my life for...
I'm so sorry.
Wait, do I...
You're trying to take advantage of me?
We almost...
It literally said, weapon will sound like a trumpet.
There is no way.
You guys are so close.
You guys almost got me.
You guys...
I can't believe it.
I could have sold this a long time ago.
You almost got me to do...
Oh my god.
It can't...
Oh!
It changed!
Guys!
Okay.
We're fine.
We're so fucking fine.
We're the fucking super collab.
Oh god.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
Super collab time.
Oh, okay.
Limited time.
Only...
Only 5,000 yen.
Oh god.
I'm so slow.
Can't be out of here.
Oh my god.
We need more speed.
Everybody's so fast!
Okay.
We have to go around.
It's okay.
At least we have like...
Holy shit.
The only thing that's saving me right now is the fact that my attack has knocked back.
Because every time I do a...
Everybody's faster than me.
Everybody is so fucking fast.
Okay.
We got...
We take this or nah?
Of course now she decides to read.
Yo.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I'm literally living because of my knock back.
There's nothing else that's fucking keeping me alive.
Okay.
Increase attack size by 15%.
Is that good or not?
The dude would have been better.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
This wouldn't have been a problem if you hadn't skipped on it.
Dude!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh my god, he's angry.
He's so fucking angry now.
I'm trying so hard to figure out... to like... maybe hope that we get...
Hope that we can get... grab a fucking magnet right now.
This is not good for me.
This is not good.
Okay.
Don't worry.
I have knockback.
They can't fuck their... they might be faster!
But I have the power of knockback!
Oh my god.
Imagine that.
Imagine the amount of money I would have made if I played endless mode.
I should have played endless mode.
I didn't... Oh my god.
Oh my god.
I could have made so much money!
Bro, this was the money maker!
This was...
This was the money maker round!
Oh no.
This is an issue right now.
This is a problem.
This is... This is a huge problem!
Oh no.
This is pretty bad.
There was a pillar!
There was a pillar chat.
I got hit.
I hit the pillar.
One pillar is all it took.
It was so close.
Okay, maybe we'll get...
We'll get...
Wait, what is it?
Is Risu also meta?
Where's Risu?
Okay.
Risu is also meta, right?
But I'm gonna do 31.
Risu is super meta?
What makes her super meta?
Oh, it's also... Okay.
It's also a...
Risu is good for money.
Okay, what is good for endgame?
Which one is... Which one is endgame material?
No doki, dude.
Sad trumpet noise.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Okay.
Damn.
Promise has like super... all the meta characters.
Alright, where the fuck is Promise?
There you go.
Alright, we'll do...
We'll do two.
Maybe two.
It'll be fine.
Come on.
Are you...
How is this possible?
Okay.
It can't happen twice in a row.
It can't happen three times in a row, right?
Okay.
We're at the pity stage.
Let's go.
Alright.
There we go.
We're at the pity now.
Alright.
We're at the pity.
Let's go!
Woo!
Wait.
No.
Okay.
We have pity.
What?
Is it Fauna or Mumei?
That's my Oshii.
Just use the tears.
Okay.
I can't believe it.
I can't fucking believe it.
I can't believe I had to pity pull for Mumei.
Like I can't fucking believe.
I have to pity pull for her.
That's so fucked up.
This is why I don't do gacha.
I swear to fucking...
Oh
my god.
Look how much I can upgrade her.
Wow.
I'm so happy.
Alright.
Let's get some stats now.
Let's grab.
Let's grab stats.
Bro.
Okay.
I don't need luck.
I earn everything.
With sheer determination and hard work.
I don't need luck.
Okay.
I need to know like...
Like I make my luck.
Okay.
It has to be two attacks.
Alright.
Let me grab the two attacks real fast.
Anya.
XP and coins.
Coin.
XP.
Pick up reins.
This last word.
Okay.
I can upgrade.
I can max everything.
Upgrade growth?
Where the fuck is growth?
What does that mean?
Max out which one?
Speed?
Where to have speed?
Okay.
What do we max out?
Upgrade coin game?
Special?
Okay.
Coin game.
And then...
Um...
What else?
Enhancements?
Oh, growth!
Oh!
Should I max it out?
Increase the damage of character in the special attacks by 1%.
Should I do it again?
Or nah?
I mean, I could do it one more.
Get to level 2?
Yeah?
Alright.
We'll do level 2.
I mean, we still have enough money.
And then...
What else do we get?
I don't know.
I can't fucking believe.
I can't fucking...
I paid to get another Mumei.
That is actually like...
How?
How is that fucking possible?
Like...
I don't know.
How is that actually possible?
Holy shit.
HP regen.
I'll do that.
And then...
Uh...
I already got fandom.
Yeah.
I got it.
Um...
Haste.
I already got...
I don't have enough for another haste.
I don't have 50,000.
Crit?
I'll grab crit.
I mean, I have like...
Crit.
XP.
Uh...
Pick up.
And...
Take HP.
You know what?
I'll crit.
Take double HP.
And then...
I'll do more...
Uh...
Let's see.
Mumei have no haste.
I do.
Wait.
Where's haste?
Guys.
I don't have haste.
I don't know why.
But like...
I like assume when you say haste.
You just try to say speed.
And I was like...
Maybe that's a British thing.
I don't know.
Maybe...
Maybe you guys are just trying...
Like...
Just saying haste.
Which means speed.
I was like...
Guys.
I do have haste.
It's times three.
Um...
Let's see.
What else?
Defense?
Alright.
We'll do defense.
We can do another defense too.
We might as well.
Alright.
There you go.
This is...
This is our loadout.
Let's go.
Alright.
Mumei.
Take me...
Take me to the holo office.
I believe in you.
I believe in you, Mumei.
You can't fail me.
We so...
Um...
Joki.
We don't say haste in the UK.
We said swift.
Learn the difference.
Joki.
Words have specific meaning.
Guys.
Alright.
Oh, bloodthirsty.
What the fuck?
Damn.
It's him.
It's Mumei time.
Do you have one or three?
Three?
Alright.
I guess because like that's like her main attack, right?
Uh...
We'll apply.
I assume that's because it's like her main attack and then I'll just max out her main attack for now.
Yeah.
I'll max out her main.
Just in case.
Alright.
Nice.
I can't believe.
I can't believe how much...
I can't believe I couldn't...
I can't believe I got fucked over by a pillar.
That's the only reason why.
Why I died.
Oh my god.
Why did the devs not warn me about Halu?
Why didn't they stop me?
They could have said something.
They could have said anything to stop me.
Okay.
Here we go.
Of course my second power up is dute.
Here's your doki dutes.
Here you go.
Here's your dute time.
Oh no.
Please tell me I can go through.
Oh!
It's already...
It's already over.
Oh my god.
I don't know how long I'm gonna be over.
It's a curse.
It's...
Am I like just the most unluckiest person?
You know what?
Maybe like...
It's...
I'm just the most unlucky person here.
Like of course.
Alright here we go.
I'm just...
I was just never meant to be lucky.
I told you.
I don't have luck.
I make my own luck.
Do hard...
It's just...
Do hard work and determination.
I'm just...
I'm not lucky.
I just earned my way through life.
Dute maxing.
The dute of fate.
Strength.
What happens when you strengthen dutes?
Do you just dute more?
Is that it?
No money.
Just a dute.
I'm just gonna...
Do I just...
Do I just dute more?
Like what the fuck happens?
It's just...
It's just louder dutes.
Alright here we go.
Boop.
Jesus Christ you're so tanky.
Alright.
That's fine.
Now I just know never go down to the corner because it's never a good idea.
Haha.
I'm getting the hang of knowing what the offices look like now.
Just dute harder.
Doki just dute harder.
It's not that difficult.
Just keep duting.
Alright let's see.
We gotta max out the feather.
Okay.
Oh no please.
Please.
Oh my...
Oh wait I can just run past that.
Increase damage.
Well that's good for now because I don't have any...
Oh my god please.
I don't have any.
I don't have any anyways so that's good.
Oh my god we're duting even...
We're doing faster!
Oh god.
Is it dute?
Dute?
Now I know...
Now I know why.
Okay.
Ida's song attack up.
We get nurse's horn.
The multiple dutes.
Haha.
Or the glasses.
The glasses?
Okay.
Alright.
Holy shit it's so fast now.
This is so fast.
Boop boop.
Are you a mini boss?
I didn't even see it.
Oh!
What the fuck?
What does that do?
What the fuck does that all do?
I got mooma scared.
Alright glasses.
Uh...
Oh!
Oh and I got a box.
Nice.
Oh it says screen wipe?
Deletes everyone.
Oh!
This is good.
Magical music notes that float vertically in both directions.
That good?
Take?
Okay.
Yeah I got...
I got mooma jump scared.
What is this?
Increase damage of weapon I might as well.
Yeah.
Oh my god.
Oh my god it's flying everywhere.
Alright.
I have more of her ult now.
This is...
I'm so prepared.
Get ready for this.
Boop.
Boop boop.
Boom boom.
Oh!
Nice upgrade.
Free upgrade.
Uh...
I guess I'll upgrade idol sign?
I mean there's nothing else to upgrade right now.
Uh...
Let's see...
Glasses?
Oh yeah I should upgrade glasses because it's like drawing XP right?
Boop boop.
Photo.
God.
This is my brain right now.
I can't commentate because all I could think about is like boop boop.
This is my brain on Holocure.
Passivist stamp.
I'm gonna swap this.
And then... intense focus.
When you stop using the trumpet, you'll miss it.
Okay, fine!
Weapon will do it harder!
Okay, fine.
Fine.
Is that what you wanted?
I'm giving you guys what you want.
The boosted dudes.
Oh my god, it's duding so fucking hard right now.
Okay.
Do we upgrade?
The poor sound gap boosted dudes.
One or two?
I see more...
tools.
I'm gonna do two.
I see more twos than ones.
You know what's crazy?
This game is like not even...
This game is not even like...
The file size is not even that big.
That's actually...
Really... like...
What's the word?
Also, strings!
Thank you for the akasupa!
Thank you!
Especially when AAA gaming...
don't know how to fucking...
Don't know how to like fucking...
stabilize game sizes.
Yeah, it's like so well optimized.
Like, a lot of AAA devs do not know how to fucking optimize games these days.
And the fact that this game is the...
I don't remember what the file size was, but I remember when I was like downloading it.
I was like, holy shit!
And like how small the game is compared to like...
Because I know there's like...
Lots of content too in Holocure.
Okay, let's see.
I guess I'll get...
Glasses.
Nice.
And we got the music notes too.
Just get a way big heart right here.
Yeah.
You can tell Akia is a fucking gamer.
Like...
Because I still can't believe...
I still can't believe that Star Wars...
Classic Battlefront is like...
How many gigabytes was that?
80 plus gigabytes?
Or was it less than that?
Like 75?
75 gigabytes?
No, Friend?
Oh, there's Friend.
So I'm gonna Friend that uses Bedfeather at...
Okay.
I'll get Friend.
Friend, it's time.
It's time to help me.
Yeah, over 70 gigabytes.
Which is fucking insane for like...
A game that's supposed to be classic.
And like...
Apparently the reason why...
Oh god, please don't hurt me.
Please don't touch me.
I don't like social interactions.
The reason why is that they forgot to like...
Resize the textures in the game.
How do you forget to resize the textures?
It wasn't even for a holiday.
I don't understand.
Okay, let's see.
What do we get?
Civilization.
I guess we could do Civilization.
Let's max that up.
Is there another arrow?
Let's look to my left.
Like...
I don't understand if they want to have the game out in time for Christmas or something.
Or for...
Oh my god, Lifesteal!
Guys, I don't know guys.
I don't know guys.
Guys, what is happening to you guys?
I must be busy right now.
This castle.
You more cold switches.
You must be cold switches.
Oh, oh my god.
Oh, I mean cold switches?
I thought I know ya.
Sorry, guys.
I cheering by myself, So cool.
I started sweating.
Oh my god.
Always upgrade, dude.
It will be harmful if this dude is any louder.
The dude, it must go on.
Alright, let's see.
Oh my god, super chat time!
Dudes and super chat time!
Just do it.
I guess like no, three or four.
Okay, guys.
Put the money.
Think about the money though.
Think about the money.
No, no.
This is level one super chat.
Level one super chat actually costs money.
Guys, guys, we can't.
Guys, level one super chat is the money super chat.
Hey guys, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
No!
You used your real money!
You had to wait until we were at level four!
Oh wait, I'm gonna wipe this out.
So I can take care of him first.
Oh god, please.
Please chill.
Alright, let's see.
Uhhh...
Dude, dude, dude.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Two?
Are you the sign?
Or one?
I see a lot of...
I'm gonna do one.
Alright.
Oh, fuck!
I can't tell that's a wall!
My last dude.
I can't tell!
It's so hard to tell!
I don't understand!
Do I have a dub?
Okay, maybe this time I'll get Fauna.
Maybe this time.
Okay, thank you for the super chat!
Okay.
I got countered!
Alright, look.
Apparently...
Guys, look.
It's not a crutch.
We're gonna...
Maybe...
We can do this.
As long as we don't keep getting two times.
No!
We don't deserve the house!
We don't deserve the office!
We don't deserve it!
No more.
Guys, it's the dude curse.
It's the fucking dude curse, okay?
It's cause we kept getting duded on.
Always stay center.
Yeah, I just realized that like...
Maybe like... going to the edges?
It's not a good idea!
Who would've thought?
The dude curse!
It's real!
Be careful!
When you pick up the dude, you can never go back.
The run is over.
The moment you start duding, the run is over.
It's not a suck cause you don't give up.
Oh my god.
No, I'm not at the center.
I'm not at the center!
Okay, it's okay.
We're fine.
We're slowly adjusting.
Oh wait, there's a...
Okay, this is very risky.
But, oh my god.
Okay, it's fine.
It's fine.
We just gotta keep moving forward.
This is it.
Ah, there's no... Okay, what do we get here?
It's the dude curse.
Three?
Okay, we get three.
We're gonna back out a little bit though.
We're gonna back out.
Ow.
It's fine.
We're fine.
Oh, box.
Another box.
It's just a burger.
We don't need the burger though.
Should be fine without it.
Uh, feather.
We gotta get all the feathers.
For the ultimate.
We gotta max out the feathers.
I'm figuring out the meta.
Very slowly.
It's okay.
The moment we max out the feathers, we can go... We can start gaming for reals.
Ooh, the flower!
What's the flower?
Taxi?
We still have 20% chance to reduce.
Okay, nice.
We got that.
We don't need the burger!
We're perfectly healthy!
Look at this.
We're perfectly healthy, guys.
Like I said, Kali was not a crutch.
We can replicate it!
Alright, nice.
Now we have maxed out.
We will be able to replicate!
I swear to god!
It's possible.
Do we take this?
Do we take the plug?
The moment I beat a Sage!
We might only be able to beat Sages on Kali, but like...
The moment we can beat another Sage with a different talent, that's when you know!
That's when you know I can game with any fucking character.
Uh...
Let's see.
Do we level up?
Or do we... We should level up.
I'm gonna level up.
Actually.
I feel like that's good to do.
Alright.
Let's see.
What do we take, guys?
1, 2, 3, 4.
Which one?
One?
Alright.
One.
It's okay.
We're gonna do this.
We're gonna beat...
We're gonna Touhou this shit.
Touhou?
I swear.
Touhou has to be... I'm...
Apparently someone said I can get an achievement if I stand here for 10 seconds.
Am I not in front of this for 10 seconds?
Yay!
That was definitely longer than 10 seconds.
I don't care.
I don't need this, but like... I just need one win in my life.
I need one win.
Alright.
Let's see.
Sage seconds are longer than real seconds.
Alright, we'll grab one.
I swear if I get one, guys, we'll grab... God damn it!
The fucking pot!
Alright, here we go.
Nice.
Oh, wait.
Get over here.
Give me your money.
I'll create the pug.
Cause I won't get a weapon closer for a collab.
I think I have...
Yeah, 3.
I might as well.
No, we do not.
We do not want...
We do not want a lollipop.
Alright.
1, 2, 3, 4.
Which one do we get?
Which one, chat?
One?
Okay.
I guess we can replace...
Wait.
I'll replace...
I'll replace this.
And then... What do we strengthen?
Here.
Do we strengthen the flower?
Or...
The... What?
The pallet?
Greed?
Okay, we'll strengthen...
We'll strengthen greed.
Might as well.
Yeah.
Oh my god.
Guys, 3 minutes.
We're at the... But like, I swear toho, I just don't know.
There's just too... I think like...
I just get like way too...
When there's just too many things on my screen, I just can't... I like panic so fucking hard.
There's just too many balls.
Don't you just hate it when there's just too many balls on the screen?
Like, come on.
Anybody...
Anybody... Anybody would freak out!
Alright.
Understandable.
Me everyday.
Okay.
Grab this.
Who's coming?
I'm coming over.
Woah.
Nice.
Oh my god.
There's too many things around now.
Alright.
We're making good progress this time.
I think it's also because I'm not getting distracted by the dudes.
The dudes aren't hurting me.
Uhhh...
Do you actually read chat?
No, I do not.
This is all pre-recorded.
My...
My psyc... If you guys don't know, I have a psychic and they tell me what you're gonna say like one week in advance.
So...
So this stream was pre-recorded.
This stream was pre-recorded like last week.
Because like everything is staged.
It's just like reality TV.
I knew it.
That's right.
You're Oshii.
Every VTuber...
Do not quote me on this.
But...
Every... Yes, I also use ChatGPT.
And I would be like, ChatGPT, I'm going to stream...
I'm going to publish my Holocure...
My Holocure VOD.
Next week.
What...
What will I have to prepare for for my chat?
50% stint... Do I take this or nah?
Do I... Do I...
The psychic don't...
Exactly, Geo!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Take?
Okay.
And then my mod is gonna be like disclaimer.
This is a bit... This is not a bit.
This whole entire stream has been...
I swear to fucking god I'm walking away.
Okay, um...
We're gonna...
We're gonna walk over there real fast.
Okay.
Wait, what's... Oh, it's just the flying.
We're fine.
Everything is fine.
If I keep going right, it's like I don't see it.
What arrow?
What arrow are you guys talking about?
There's no arrows anywhere.
What?
What arrows are you talking about?
But anyway, as I was saying, it's crazy.
AI is too strong now.
AI has predicted the future for streaming.
All I do is just be like, ChatGPT, what is my...
What is my chat gonna tell me today when I stream Holocure?
And then they're gonna be like, oh, Doki...
They're gonna be like, in DokiBird's Holocure stream, there is going to be...
What do I upgrade?
I guess I'll upgrade greed.
There is... Wait, actually, is this even good?
Increase attack size.
Do we need attack size?
Is that good?
I'm actually in ChatGPT, by the way.
ChatGPT!
Is this good?
If you see me looking to the right, it's actually the ChatGPT screen.
Because...
Because obviously I can't re-chat because it's pre-recorded.
Okay.
We are...
You guys are a ChatGPT.
Let's see.
I feel like 2.
Civilization.
Nice.
Good job, friend.
Okay, as I was saying...
Uh...
That actually shows how good of a streamer I am.
It just feels so real.
Oh my god.
She's so good at streaming that it doesn't even feel like it's pre-recorded.
I know!
It doesn't!
I'm gonna grab the fork because I need a...
AI is true.
Oh my god!
Did you guys hear about the dead internet theory?
Like every...
If you ever look at like popular posts from like big Twitter accounts, there'd be like...
It's just bots.
It's cause of like...
Cause of Elon Musk's fucking...
Like... Oh, like advertising.
Fucking monetization shit.
For those who don't know what the dead internet theory is...
Let me open this box first.
It's just...
The world is becoming more and more infested in bots.
Like in the internet.
Yeah, it's just all fucking internet.
They just... They actually use ChatGPT and AI to make Twitter responses.
It's so fucking weird.
It's so weird.
Holy shit.
It's like Y2K.
It's like modern day Y2K.
Um...
Buddy friend.
You only have three...
Three...
It's like chat is just...
My entire chat is just...
It's just AI.
So like...
If you ever go on like those popular...
like meme Twitter accounts.
Or not just like news Twitter accounts.
Or like just like... Wait, what achievement?
Don't take any damage for five seconds?
Oh shit, I did it.
I'm fucking gaming.
Uh... But basically like...
They actually use like...
Oh wait, okay.
Oh my god, but there's super chat time.
We have become high mod and ChatGPT.
All our base blood are ChatGPTs.
Thank you, thank you.
It's actually so scary though.
Oh no, like...
I think they haven't targeted VTubers yet.
Like VTubers are not targeted yet.
Like viral posts.
But you ever look...
No!
My five minute not take damage!
But...
But you ever look at any...
Viral post or anything.
It's mostly just like...
Bot accounts.
And the reason why they do that is because...
They can sell Twitter accounts.
To like for... Oh fuck!
Upgrade!
Sorry, give me a sec.
This is... This is important.
Oh shit, nice.
What do we get here?
I mean, it's not... We're not talking about like link in bio.
It's not the link in bio shit.
It's like actual like...
Replies to your tweets.
It's like replies to your tweets that feel like...
Real people type responses to it.
Cause they're trying to get reactions to it.
And stuff.
And then...
Pulling the wall.
It's not that.
It's like actual viral tweets.
That have like...
That are like there to like...
Get likes and follows.
And...
Even like...
If we started on YouTube because it's like the MrBeast shit.
Um... God, what do we want?
SuperTweets?
Or ChattoTime?
Or Bloodthirsty?
What do we want?
Do we invite you?
Okay, here we go.
But like, it's cause like... The reason why they do that...
Is cause...
And they're always verified too.
They're always verified to take advantage of the monetization.
For Elon Musk shit.
Cause like they're like...
Oh, we have like...
A viral tweet.
Then like...
Get out!
Leave!
Stop!
Okay, sorry.
So many things are going on right now.
The reason why...
And also they can sell Twitter accounts for money as well.
Alright, do we get three or four?
This stream is very interesting.
Thank you for making Super Chat Kid!
Thank you, thank you!
Tomato and Pie.
Two?
Wait...
Three or four?
Three.
Okay.
And then we can...
Max level this.
What is this?
Okay, we might as well.
Cause we already have book.
So people can sell Twitter accounts as well.
Cause the more followers...
You know what's like... What is it?
What was that Twitter account?
There was this really big popular Twitter account.
Oh yeah!
Images before they became popular!
So there was this really...
Big Twitter account.
That was like images before they became viral or some shit.
And that guy sold his Twitter account for like...
Ten thousand dollars or something.
That's fucking crazy!
Cause it was like...
Yeah cause then they like...
They like...
The Twitter account suddenly changed into some...
NFT shit or something.
Like...
Like... It suddenly changed into some...
NFT shit.
And then people were like... What the fuck?
Yeah!
Origins of...
Iconic...
Like yeah that shit.
And then...
Yeah they fucking sold it.
And then the guy was like... Yeah I've had offers.
Like or crypto.
It was either NFT or crypto.
And then they were like...
And then other popular Twitter accounts were like...
Yeah we get like lots of offers.
For...
We get like a shitload of offers.
For like...
My Twitter account that has like...
I don't know... 500k followers or some shit.
I don't know like...
It's like...
People would wanna buy the account.
Oh hey look.
What is this?
Projectiles.
Oh wait projectiles Sam!
That's really good!
Let's see... What is that?
Swap what?
Swap.
Okay.
And then we'll swap this.
And then we'll...
I guess we'll strengthen one.
Oh.
Get out.
Okay what I'm really worried about is...
Bomb guy.
Bomb guy freaks me out.
Yeah.
I mean it's the same thing with...
Uh... Fuck.
They did that with YouTube accounts too.
Where they get to a hundred... Is that desk?
Oh okay.
I was like what the fuck is that?
They do that with like YouTube accounts as well.
They try to get it.
They try to get it to like a hundred K.
Like back then when the whole...
There was like a meta...
Where... Oh my god!
Big...
I'm not fast.
I'm fast enough.
Oh no no no no.
No no no.
No no.
No.
Okay don't worry.
I'm fast enough though.
Okay.
I'm just gonna...
I'm just gonna be over here.
Give me a sec.
Oh my god!
What is the rage?
I need to get into an open space!
This is bad.
I'm not like in an open...
Oh my god.
Okay.
I don't wanna look at it.
I don't wanna look at this.
Get me outta here.
No I don't see.
I don't perceive.
If I don't look it's like it doesn't exist.
If I...
If I don't look it's not there.
Guys that's how I'm gonna go with life.
Just don't look.
If I don't look it doesn't exist.
I might as well max that out.
Oh three!
I might as well take all of that.
Yeah.
The cooking and the...
...bruchetto.
And then we enhance...
Might as well enhance the...
We'll enhance the book.
Let's see.
You cannot run...
I'm running!
You can't stop me!
Oh shit collab!
Nice.
Got the collab time.
Alright.
Back then...
Back then the meta for YouTube accounts...
...was to be everywhere with comments.
So like...
You'd be like...
Alright.
Do we strengthen this?
Or do we swap this?
We can max out the...
The...
The weaken stamp.
Get gorilla paw?
Okay get gorilla paw.
Swap?
Swap two.
Okay.
Alright.
And we'll strengthen.
Confirm.
But yeah back... You know like back in old YouTube...
The meta was to like...
Have... Just... Oh shit.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Here we go.
We're gonna max out book.
Just to have like... Just to be everywhere...
...with YouTube comments.
So every YouTube...
...viral... Viral YouTube video...
You'll see like the same...
...five people commenting...
...on YouTube.
And then they'll say...
...sell their accounts afterwards.
Cause it's like so... That's like easy...
...subscribers.
It was just so easy to get subscribers.
And then they'll sell the YouTube account.
And then...
And then it's like free YouTube play button.
Like free like...
...head start and stuff for those who are like...
...they'll sell it to like...
...some fucking content creator that wants like...
...more subscribers or something.
And then like... And then at one point...
...they were like... They started hacking other...
...channels too.
They were like...
...hacking YouTube channels.
So they can sell the YouTube channels...
...and stuff for money.
It's fucking crazy.
Let's see.
Do we want... We don't want...
...this right?
Do we want this or nah?
Do we strengthen it?
Upgrade too.
Okay.
It's crazy.
The things people will do for money...
...is actually insane.
But yeah, this is why...
...this is why like...
...
No, we're backing the trumpet.
Why do I keep coming back to you?
We get the gorilla paw, right guys?
Now they just hacked in the show...
...NFT scams.
Yeah, or crypto scams.
We get the monkey paw, right?
The gorilla paw?
Two.
Okay.
We'll grab two.
And then we'll have a super collab.
Oh god.
I cannot see anything.
I cannot.
We're at the stage where I can't see anything.
I always come back to that trumpet.
Why can I never quit you?
AHHHHH Okay.
Oh, here we go.
It's fine.
Everything is fine.
We're at the center.
We're all okay.
We'll get the spider cookie.
To sell the trumpet.
No, it's here to punish you all.
So you...
So you know wherever I go...
...you will know where that green arrow is.
Everywhere I go, you will know...
...what this green arrow is.
Just to tempt all of you guys forever.
It'll always be there.
I'm tempting you.
Telling you to be like...
I'm here.
I'm right here.
The dude.
Get ready for the dudes.
Alright, let's see.
What did I get here?
Do I just max out Gorilla Paul?
Awesome.
Logical.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Watching you play inspired me to get the game.
I beat the first stage with Ami and just beat the second with Gurra.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
For, right?
We maxed the Paul for the...
Okay, maxed the Paul for the super collab.
Alright, that's fine.
That's good to know.
Alright, here we go.
Oh yeah!
I was trying to fucking do a Zatsu about...
...all of this.
I almost forgot.
There's just so many things happening on my screen.
But, oh my...
Okay, wait.
Let me think real fast.
Okay.
Oh yeah, it's actually...
Like, I don't know if they did like...
...personal... Oh fuck, wait.
Give me a sec guys.
There's two...
I'll never be able to talk about Holofest because there's always things happening.
Okay, what do we want?
One, two, three, four.
Four?
Throw an axe?
Or two?
Four?
Okay, we'll get four.
Why is this open?
Alright, that's good.
We just got the axe too.
What is this?
Reduce special cooldown by 45% allows a special...
Do we get this?
Or nah?
Take or nah?
Is this a... take?
Oh, okay.
This is super rare.
Oh my god.
Is my luck changing?
This is it!
My luck is turning around!
This is it, Mumei!
We're doing it!
My luck is finally turning around!
It's here!
Holy shit.
It's actually here.
Oh my god.
Alright, here we go.
But no, I'm like...
Oh my god.
Fuck!
Please!
I'll never...
I'll never be able to talk about Holofest.
Alright, Gorilla Pop.
Everything is just too many things on my screen.
We're too close.
I like how you were like, Just all so we can hear the tangents!
Doki!
Just fucking all!
We wanna know about what you think about Holofest!
Just all!
No.
I want the money.
I want the money too.
Fine.
But it doesn't give me the money!
But it just...
It's like that screen wipe thing!
Guys, it doesn't...
I wanna have the money!
The money is so good!
Yeah, move...
The ult sucks.
I hate the ult.
I don't like... Oh wait, fuck.
Okay, never mind.
This is good.
It's good now.
There was just way too many batteries.
Oh no, is this like the...
Wait, we gotta grab the axe here.
We gotta grab the axe here.
And then...
The money!
Guys, how am I supposed to beat Touhou?
If I don't get rich here.
In Holokir.
The fuck am I supposed to beat...
Beat Touhou?
That's actually my greatest weakness, Touhou.
Alright, we gotta kill the battery.
Nice!
Battery gun.
Okay.
Monkey paw?
Three!
Oh, super energy drink.
Wait, is this really good?
Wait, this is... Is this an SSR?
Oh shit!
Nice.
Now I'm super fast.
Wait, there's four arrows?
What the fuck did I... Oh, I'm so fucking fast.
Oh my god.
I'm so fucking fast.
Okay, can we max?
Okay, we're gonna sell this.
Alright.
I'm gonna sell the... Do I sell this?
Chat?
No, I finished upgrading everything.
I'm pretty sure.
Yeah, everything's maxed.
Alright.
I fucking knew it.
I knew my luck was gonna change!
Woman, I've always believed in you.
I told you!
The dude is the curse!
I fucking knew it!
I knew it.
I fucking knew the dudes were the curse.
All this time.
Yeah.
God!
Never took the trumpet!
Suddenly get two SSRs?
Coincidence?
I think not.
I knew it.
I knew it was a fucking curse in the end.
I fucking called it.
Where the fuck is the bomb?
I'm like so worried about the bomb right now.
Oh!
Okay.
I was not...
I was not doing so well with that.
I need that burger.
Please give me that burger.
Okay.
Super collab!
What is it?
Wait, what do we combine?
What do we combine here?
What do we combine?
Dragon fire!
Wait.
No soup.
Dragon fire and...
Okay.
Axe plus book.
It's time to eat some black licorice again.
Okay.
Here we go.
Oh my god.
I can't see anything.
Okay.
We actually have to tone this down now.
This is like too much.
This is actually too much on my screen.
Holy fuck.
Okay.
We need to grab...
Oh hey.
We need to...
Is this good?
Okay.
We can sell this.
Oh I don't have hammer?
Yeah.
I need to find a hammer.
That green thing over there?
That's the dude.
If I keep it there, I'll have good luck.
Uhhhhh...
Let's see.
One earth.
One, two, three, four.
Pirate, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Take that.
Alright.
Uhhhhh...
Hammer?
Head...
Lava?
Okay.
I don't know why I said hammer.
I meant lava.
My brain is not working so well.
I've been playing holo cure for like three hours already.
Wooo!
Hammer!
I got the hammer!
Guys we just need the monkey paw!
Oh god.
Oh!
Do I take this now?
Or do I wait until monkey paw?
Do I take that now or wait?
Now?
Okay.
What do I do?
This?
Monkey paw!
Okay.
That's it?
Is that it?
Yes.
Yeah?
Oh okay.
What do I get?
Holy fire.
Spits flames which contains the strength of 50 kg.
All attack damage is also multiplied.
Holy shit.
Alright.
Oh my god.
Can we get super chat?
Now super chat is free for sure.
Oh no.
Okay.
Uhhhhhhh...
Do we sell this or keep?
Sell?
Sell.
Okay.
Oh no it's him.
Oh no please.
Please.
There's no way that I was gonna say I'm so fucking strong now there's no fucking way.
Alright.
We're gonna grab more super chat.
Oh my god.
What is my screen?
What?
Let's go back and just grab everything I missed.
Oh my... They can't even walk anymore!
I fucked them up!
Oh there's this knockback.
It's so confusing.
I don't know what's a character and what's an attack anymore.
It's like such a blur.
I feel like I can actually stand still.
I'm pretty sure I can actually just stand still and not have to worry about it.
Yeah I'm at that stage.
I'm definitely at that stage.
Alright.
Uhhhhhhh...
Alright headphones.
Oh no never mind I can't.
I can't keep... Okay I can!
I can kill them!
That's right I have all the powers!
I have every perm except for Nintendo because I'm a straight up Nintendo.
Alright.
Uhhhh lava.
Okay we're gonna grab...
Do we get bomb or nah?
Do the... give in to the dude.
Sneeze thank you for the super chat!
Thank you thank you!
Clock thank you for the super chat!
I'm gonna get super chat.
One fear Nintendo.
Alright.
The one company you do not wanna piss off.
They have...
They have like so much power.
They don't...
Because it's like one of those...
It's like a company that's more so of like...
Um...
They know they have so much good publicity that like bad publicity doesn't hurt them.
Because they hold...
They hold so much good publicity at that point that like they can just release a new Zelda game and people will just forget.
Like... No!
It's true!
You can be like Wow Nintendo.
Why would you do that?
And then the moment they announce a new Zelda game everybody will forget all the bad shit.
They booed her because she's right!
Sadly true.
Do we sell or keep this?
Do we...
Swap?
Okay.
Do we swap or sell?
Sell.
Okay I'm gonna sell.
You can't boo her because she's right.
It's true.
It's so true.
No.
She's coming.
Oh no.
It's Touhou.
No.
Not Touhou!
I can't do Touhou!
Like it's so bad because I can't...
I actually can't see!
I can't see my attacks!
I can't see!
It's bad because I don't know I don't know where... which was her attack and which one is mine!
That's not what it's about.
Oh god.
Oh I did it!
I did it!
Look at me!
We did it!
Holy fuck!
Okay.
I knew it!
Mumei no!
I know you couldn't fucking disappoint me!
Holy shit.
Nice.
We did it.
Oh!
We did it guys.
Oh my god.
Let's go to Mumei's house.
Let's go.
Hello Mumei.
What is this?
Oh my god they're all here!
What are you doing?
This is my fucking...
village!
Do I have enough money?
Where's my fishing?
Okay.
Fishing.
Beginner's rod.
Dad's rod.
Golden rod.
Okay.
How do I sell?
Exchange?
Talk?
Welcome to the fish shop.
I'm Bloop and I trade in fishing goods.
Okay.
How do I fish?
Hello.
Oh.
Guys.
I...
Guys!
I don't have the right keyboard!
I don't have arrow keys!
Like...
Okay.
Now we're good.
Here we go.
Boom.
Wait.
What?
Is this not arrow keys?
How?
I'm using the arrow keys!
It's WASD?
Okay.
It's WASD.
How the fuck?
I see arrow key.
How the fuck am I supposed to know?
Like...
My brain goes like...
Oh.
Hey.
Arrow key.
Oh shit.
I got two now.
Are these real people?
Are you real people?
Can I have more stuff?
Hello.
Are you real?
Aww.
That would be great if they were real.
I was gonna say like...
Give me all your fish.
If you're real.
Oh my god.
The real game.
Nice.
What do I do?
Can I sell my fish?
I guess I sell my fish for stuff, right?
So the more fish I have...
They're chat GPT.
They're also...
Why can't I not recruit my fans?
To fish for me!
I can't believe it.
This is fucked up.
I can't like...
I can't have my fans...
fish for me.
So I can...
Oh I can cook!
I can make tempura!
Increase attack by... What do I need attack for?
Is it for like just this run?
What is this?
Manage, hire, send out...
an advertisement to get recruits.
Do I... Can I... Oh!
Can I collect my fans here?
Eww.
They are cooked.
Why do I need... Oh thank you!
Okay, why do I need a cook?
Okay, I'll make one tempura.
I don't have enough money for tempura.
How do I...
How do I like...
Okay, let's see.
Bye.
Is there a way to like...
How do I collect my fans?
How do I steal other people's fans?
I think that's like the better question.
Just lead me to my...
I guess.
Hire.
Oh I have to hire people.
Okay.
I can't believe I have to pay the money!
Let's see.
We'll grab a...
What can I make you do?
Tomato.
Alright.
Status.
We like curling...
I don't have tomatoes!
There, you're a bird now.
I mean, it's the closest to a...
It's the closest to a dragoon.
I can't believe it's a tomato too.
What do you do?
Collection?
Give me your money.
Give me your fucking...
Give me your fucking money, dragoon.
Nice.
That's fucking right.
EARN ME THE MONEY!
My lunch money.
Alright, we gotta fucking plant a tomato apparently.
Put me in boss.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Kato, thank you for the super chat.
I know it hurts.
But you might have to read.
No!
Never!
You'll never get me to read.
Alright, wait.
What about my fucking...
I don't have standard soil?
Okay.
Standard soil.
Okay, I'm gonna get enhanced soil.
I have...
I have the money for this.
Okay.
Just a plant.
A tomato.
There we go.
I have to feed my dragoon somehow.
That's right.
That's fucking right, grant.
That's fucking right.
EARN YOUR KEEP!
Hello.
Alright, I should buy like something.
Let me buy...
Uhhh...
We'll buy a...
We'll just buy a... We'll buy a gamer chair.
We'll buy... Okay, we're...
Yellow gamer chair.
What the fuck?
It's 75 thousand dollars?
Bro!
This gamer chair better fucking fix my back.
My back's okay, but...
I better never have back problems in my life.
After that.
Like, what the fuck?
Do I have to water my tomato?
Just die.
75 thousand...
Bro, okay.
I can't believe it.
I'm gonna sleep on the fucking floor.
Like, why the fuck is the...
Bro!
And the night...
I'm fucking buying this zero dollars.
Bro.
This is way too fucking expensive, man.
Bro, we're gonna sleep on the fucking couch.
Apparently... What the fuck?
What are these guys doing there?
Are you okay, Kiara?
Alright.
Okay, inventory.
Apparently...
Wait, build mode.
How do I fucking put my stuff here?
Okay.
Bed.
There you go.
That's it.
That's all I need.
Oh wait, I can...
Wait, can I put a shrimp?
No.
This is all I need.
There you go.
Nice.
I can't.
I'm stuck.
Did I just find a bug?
Of course.
If it's anybody, it's me.
Okay, here we go.
There we go.
Of course.
Only I can find bugs.
Alright.
So when you place it on top of a person, you get stuck.
You get stuck.
Who would've thought?
What the fuck are you doing here?
Do I have a pet army too?
What are you doing there?
Oh my god, you're earning your money.
Nice.
Good job.
I already saw what's behind the house.
There's a bunch of these guys.
These fuckers over here.
Yeah.
Later.
Yeah, what are you guys doing, huh?
Yeah, what the fuck are you guys doing over there, huh?
She's keeping them in line.
Feed us?
I don't have food!
Oh my god, I have to water.
Just chill.
You'll get your fucking food soon.
Chill.
Eww.
Or you can starve, I don't know.
Alright.
You know what?
Oh my god, I can talk about my Zazudon!
Oh my god.
Anyway, as I was saying, for HoloFest shit, that shit was so fucking...
I don't know, I'm pretty sure some of them must... You have to do dance classes and stuff.
I remember I had to...
I did personal dance classes and everything too.
And like, oh my god, it's so much work!
So like, I know how like, it's like, that plus tenfold, cause they're doing a concert too.
Like, oh my god.
I would like, for me, I remember, like, I did dance classes every other day.
And I had like the hardest fucking choreo.
I chose the hardest fucking choreo too.
Cause I was like, um, I really wanna dance really well.
And I remember like, oh my god.
Like, seeing that, I'm like, oh god.
They must have fucking... did so much fucking work for that shit.
Like...
Like, the flips and everything.
I'm like, Jesus, that is so tiring.
That is so fucking tiring.
And I like...
I paid for those personal dance classes for myself.
Like... OH!
TOMATO!
Give me a sec.
I gotta give you guys some tomatoes.
Uh, it's super intense.
And I like, paid for my own personal dance classes too.
So, like, cause I wanted to dance really, really well.
And then, um, I remember just doing like a month straight of just non-stop dance classes every other day.
Oh my god, it rains?
There's weather?!
Okay, we're gonna... Can I feed you guys?
How do I feed you?
Feed.
Oh shit.
Oh, you can level up?
Oh, that's cool.
I'm gonna level you...
Now you want potato?
Alright, I'm firing you now.
You're getting fired now.
Cause...
How dare you.
I can't believe it.
You can ditch your...
You can ditch like that?
How fucking dare you!
How could you?!
Look at me!
How could you?
I can't believe you wanted potatoes!
Potatoes!
I'm so fucking weird.
Please, I have a family.
Yeah?!
And your family decided you wanna eat potatoes?!
You're not a real goon.
You're not...
You're not a real dragoon.
Oh shit, free fish.
Free fish.
There's no balanced diet, it's just tomatoes.
This is a tomato family!
Dragoon.
This is literally a tomato family!
How dare you!
Straight from the family heritage!
Heritage!
Alright.
Anyway.
I think this is a good time to call it.
I had a lot of fun!
Honestly, like the hours passed by so fucking fast.
Um...
It actually has been like incredibly fun playing Holocure.
I never...
I didn't think I'd be like...
I just knew it was like super addicting, but like oh my god I didn't realize how addicting this game is.
And I honestly had an incredible time playing it.
And uh...
Oh, I'm gonna call it here guys.
Thank you guys so much for watching everybody.
As always everyone, stay hydrated, posture check, get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you, except for me, head to bed cause you deserve it!
I'll see you guys next time everybody.
Bye guys!
Bye!